oh
[Music]
dude what is this
is
yes
[Music]
no
oh i just that up dude
yes
it's fine i've waited
it's fine everything it's fine
[Music]
fine it's fine we're good
you
came in my
[Music]
is
oh i'm pinned there
[Music]
wait
hey i'm so lost here
[Music]
this is too fast dude
i can't do five minutes this is bad i
need to do ten minutes i can't play five
minutes
bad idea five times five minutes is a
bad idea did i have no wait no back back
back
[Music]
damn soul
this is bad five minutes is bad no abort
stop putting me at five
okay there we go
five minutes is too fast dude that
shit's crazy there's no that's literally
impossible
[Music]
i don't know i don't want to go here
dude
what are these openings
[Music]
this guy is playing kind of weird
okay queen's coming out um
as i move here
is move here
my take
[Music]
i don't want to go with you
my
[Music]
um
oh you know maybe i should push that up
there
damn
too late now
[Music]
how i accidentally became the biggest
chess streamer of all time me
how is that possible
oh please don't hurt me
oh my god
[Music]
don't worry
i'm down here guys
uh
i saw you big man hey yay
[Music]
i am not a chess streamer i don't know
what i'm doing
i was just trying to draw a line but
accidentally dragged that
am i dead
we can kill him
no what wait what
i want a refund
[Music]
in as much cash as you can carry you can
keep i don't care if you put in your
pockets and your hoodie and your pants
and your shoes you know i still need to
whip out my camera and
put on
a smile
to get my picture taken paul champs
competitor here
oh my god
[Music]
hey guys welcome to thanks thanks for
the host
yeah moving the pawn out two squares hey
yo this move here is too rare he got the
two pawns out there as friends yeah
night came around yo we ready to end oh
my god the queen making moves already
yeah pull the queen out yo this dude is
heavy yeah and y'all know knights move
at the angle you're stepping up the mag
[Music]
welcome ladies and gentlemen to
pogchamps 4 presented by coinbase we've
got three awesome matchups for you today
i'm grandmaster daniel naradiski and it
is a pleasure to be commentating today
with women's grandmaster nemo xiao
nemo good afternoon how are you doing
are you excited about today's pogchamps
matchups
good afternoon i am extremely excited
about today's podcast matchups
maybe a little bit biased as well
because i do have two of my own students
playing but you know it's going to be
such an exciting day
no you're absolutely not allowed you're
not allowed not allowed not a lot i am
also very excited neil and let's have a
quick look at
all of our participants and as usual
what a field it is we've got ludwig
we've got some people returning and nemo
we've got a lot of people making their
debut uh including today anybody that
you've sort of kept an eye on or been
surprised by their performance so far
yeah so i mean today we do have some
very interesting matchups we got jake
playing we got bundy playing we have
tekton playing cutie so many awesome
people but i have been really surprised
by the very rapid improvement by jake
probably because he went from having
never played chess before
and like not knowing what amphisong is
to you know actually holding his own
against ludwig the other day so
super happy about that lots of really
exciting games to be
seen today
absolutely and well maybe that's due to
the awesome coaching but we'll be
getting into the game soon however if
you missed yesterday's matches don't
worry we've got the coinbase recap
uh for you to review all of the best
moments from the day let's take a look
he doesn't see it
is she gonna find
it oh wait let's just check mate dammit
dude i'm so bad at chess
if he moves his
[Laughter]
i think jimmy really wants to make a
comeback he even messaged in between the
games in the chat for a bit of a help
someone help tell me the cheat codes to
chests
jack made next move he knows it
so you can only go here beast and i mean
mr beast we got a new beast in town five
make five up we won we got it so i do
this thing um it's actually pretty cool
not a lot of people do it but once i
start losing i um get significantly
worse i just like can't think and i just
choke so hard
and that's what you're witnessing right
now it's pretty cool it's called the
cutie gambit
um
it's one of my favorites
he's just going to take that because he
just wants to simplify which makes sense
oh
no he's gonna can i resign
then it's okay it's not over
plus two it's not awful not over it's
not a duma
it's not over you didn't like the arnold
welcome to california no is that is it
that bad
and i blamed everyone mostly i blamed
anna for a little bit i blamed le levy
the only person you can't blame is me
you can't blame me no go yourself
daddy you said we could have a lesson
where you came
you got busy too it's not my fault
well right now i like to blame everyone
else
um
maya showed up at my house with a gallon
of wine what was i supposed to do say no
to maya
i've done the calculations
[Music]
oh wait wait what what oh my god
los vegas
position
oh
i almost dropped my first f-bomb ever
that was ridiculous
[Music]
i don't feel the thing
and i stopped remembering
days are just music
[Music]
i'm enjoying this so much
oh
[Music]
my gosh
i could have won i actually could have
won there dude i had a really good
position i think
damn you
[Music]
well
nemo i'll put it this way i don't know
if danny's arnold schwarzenegger accent
was deserving to be in those highlights
but those were some amazing moments
ludwig's face hannah's reaction at the
ends nemo this is why we watch pog chips
those are some awesome moments
absolutely absolutely for all of the
amazing you know not even chess related
moments both all of these competitors
just bring so much in terms of
entertainment and also
you know the sure will to be willing to
play in a tournament it's not easy to
play in chess tournament we've been
playing gesture events for a little bit
but even now it's difficult so i can
only imagine how difficult it is for all
the participants of this pog chance
that's absolutely true it always is so
nerve-wracking but that's also what
makes it fun and yes i'm sorry danny i
hope i can keep my job
uh well we wanted to remind you that
chess.com is happy to be supporting rise
above the disorder in their cause to
remove the two greatest barriers to
mental health care access and
affordability started by a world of
warcraft guild leader in 2013
rad has helped tens of thousands of
people all over the world receive mental
health care free of charge
go to chess.comrad
that's rad to make a donation and
remember chess.com will be matching up
to 100k yep that is 100 000
of the community's contributions
great stuff nemo and let's have a quick
look at today's pairings we've got three
amazing match-ups you mentioned jake and
bake that is your protege
yeah any thoughts about any of these
matchups i think they're all going to be
really really interesting fundy of
course uh he's super strong as well so
a couple of people will have to do quite
the uphill climb today
yeah i mean i i do think that these
matchups are going to be quite close
uh jake plays absolutely amazing chess
but at the cost of his time which is
typically how it goes for a lot of newer
players right like if you have a limited
time then you're probably likely to find
some better moves but
let's see if today he'll be able to find
the balance between making good moves as
well as this time and
you know obviously some very exciting
stuff is going to happen from cutie
versus tech tone i can just see the
piece of spine off the board already
there's going to be some tall like
sacrifices of course nick is going to
play his uh second match up so we'll see
if he can get his revenge against fundy
and we'll be jumping into those matches
very very soon uh we wanted to remind
you that pogchamps is presented by
coinbase whether you're looking to make
your first crypto purchase or you're an
experienced trader coinbase has you
covered visit coinbase.com chess and get
five dollars in bitcoin when you sign up
and verify your account that sounds
like a pretty sweet deal to minimal
except they already have an account
you already have an account i don't have
one yet so i could still proud card
carrying member
all right well the games will begin soon
we are going to go on a quick break and
when we come back we will begin our
first matchup don't go anywhere we'll be
back in just a few
yeah
so you just get the pawn out and you get
the bishop out to f5 okay okay
and um
here you can take it doesn't really
matter you're just going to build this
fortress that's all that matters okay
all right i don't know if i'll do that
but i'll try
yeah good luck wait so show me the black
can you flip the board for me or how do
i flip it yes
space hit hit x if you hit x you can oh
okay
yeah
can you show me one more black opening
um
these are the two or is there anything
you'd want or need
so here yeah you just uh do this
and if they do the same thing you can
just
go and defend yourself and do this
bishop d7 idea you've been playing this
way okay okay
and what you're trying to do is again
going to castle quickly and if d4 you
just capture
they capture you block so if they pin
you you own pin mr unpin is coming okay
got it all right it's and if they give
up something over here you just take it
because this is objectively really bad
for your opponent okay okay
all right best of luck
okay sounds good i'll try to remember
these things
yeah and uh yeah you you you'll do
you'll do good all right all right best
of luck all right thank you
chess weave everybody he just helped me
out a little bit we need a stretch can
you get the blood flow in here guys
let's get it flowing
wait twitch.tv
chess
oh they're watching me again ah crap
let's get it
all right well i need some warm-up music
dude
i'm gonna do some stretching before we
go in here
all right everybody
we
didn't play our best the very first day
you know we were a little nervous we
learned a lot specifically about time we
need to move faster what do we do we
trained in time we put the angle weights
on and we played these time matches and
we got through them all we won about 70
percent of them
at a 1000 mmr easy peasy lemon squeezy
say we go against five up one of the
biggest five head sleepers on twitch doc
tv
oh i've known about this guy since among
us in fact
in fact
i think i might have been one of the
only people on the platform he was
worried about and among us because he
knew the skills the strategies that we
have under our belts and in our drawers
and in our pants
but today
is a day of redemption boys with the
help of
chess weeb
nemo
and our own damn little noggin
we're taking this home baby let's
stretch up
welcome back to pogchamps 4 presented by
coinbase and the best way to stay up to
date on all fog shams happenings is to
follow us on your favorite social media
channels especially our discord because
right now you can join our park champs
discord channel to tell us who you're
rooting for in pogjams4 and
our sponsor coinbase will be giving out
diamond memberships during the
tournament to members of the pogchamps
discord channel so don't miss out on
awesome discussions and great prizes use
command x glam contest that's exclam
contest in the chat and join for your
chance at a diamond membership on
chess.com
all right well before we jump into our
first matchup let's have a quick look at
the format nemo i personally really like
the format i think it's elegant i think
it gives players a chance to shine what
do you think
yeah i fully agree i mean
you know being split into four groups of
four players means right off the bat you
are at least guaranteed to be playing a
few games uh you know you might not be
super excelling at chess already but you
do have the opportunity to play against
people of similar strength and there are
two brackets as well so you not only get
one opportunity to perform you get two
opportunities to perform
so there's some pretty good stuff
over here
it definitely is particularly for less
experienced players they get a chance at
the consolation bracket the time control
10 minutes per game plus five second
increment which means there are five
seconds added to each player's clock
when they make a move eliminates the
possibility of crazy time scrambles
although as you correctly pointed out
nemo
time plays a big role and we've seen
many times these players take a little
bit too long uh on a move it's a
trade-off we'll definitely get into that
but first let's get into two days
pairing we have five up
facing off against jake and bake live
and as we speak the first game has begun
five up as the white pieces nemo you've
worked with jake
uh what do you rank
his play in the opening how confident
has he been throughout your lessons as
we see wow d45 that is not common for
pog jumps we usually see e4
most certainly you either see e4 or you
see the london there is no in between
the rest of all the d4 openings in the
world cease to exist for the most part
but
um
while i want to be you know full of
praise for jake and his chest
unfortunately this is not an opening we
really got to got around to uh covering
so
he is on his own here i told him to
control the center and develop his
pieces let's see how good of a job he
does on that
well he's played f6 which is not uh
conventionally how black plays in one
usually that square is reserved for the
knight but look at jake going e5
claiming control of the center
this is not bad especially if he
continues developing maybe get one of
the bishops out
uh five up playing very solid chess
playing the sort of typical london setup
neither side really doing anything
terribly wrong so far
yeah looking like a pretty solid
position i mean there is always a joke
right you don't really want to push up
your f-bomb because it does weaken your
king a little bit but
i'm not too worried for jake actually
right now because if queen to h5 we do
at least have g6 and
now maybe a little bit more worried
about quick h5 just you know just making
sure you have that g60 predictor bishop
or bishop g6 to prevent you from losing
but you're right i always feel like uh
any undefended pieces are a cause for
worrying pop jumps we've seen lots of
forks lots of skewers and
the more chaos there is on the board i
think the greater
probability that something interesting
is going to happen jake took a while in
that move and now it's
five ups turn to think bishop d3 very
solid they're like you know two russian
grand masters
to learn the london let's listen in
like this piece is he's either going to
take it or it's going to become
worthless if he takes then i take and
then he pushes that probably
it's not bad though in 97
wow
hey slow
okay
i like this move because you are just
developing and protecting a piece at the
same time i guess i could do
do i want to block the queen
it does pin this piece
ends my night but i think i want to do
this so i can cancel i just want to
castle as quick as possible
um
i take heat
i can't go here because then he does
this and then i cry
i could go here all the time too buddy
and he take
and i go here
we would always die
like
this
it's just a mess we're just going to go
the simple good old move and castle
i like this move i mean if you play
knight jeff three
oh it was actually big
oh wow they just both castled instantly
and we've got opposite side castling
which i love to see in podcast because
that probably means both sides are
starting the attack on either side
something spicy is about to come and i
mean
him playing 97 was a 92 sorry it was
really good because there was actually
e4 there with the little fork so he did
avoid that by playing 92 and opposite
side costling is something i think jake
is going to rather enjoy he knows the
concept of putting your pieces towards
your opponents and you know shoving all
your pawns off the board absolutely
um and i did tell him always play
aggressive chess in blitz because it's
much easier to be attacking than it is
to be defending so uh you know
i'm just a little bit worried that
yeah oh
that's a very tricky move nemo because
guess what he's taking away the b5 score
from the bishop and now black is
threatening to play e4 when the bishop
is going to be trapped
so i'm a little bit worried for for five
up here
because attempting move would just be to
get the night out let's say play knight
d2 or knight a3
and it's very easy to miss why a move
like h6
is played i would be very impressed if
five up takes the bishop now which is
probably what he should do
but
i'm worried that he's gonna just go
knight d2
uh or maybe even push one of his queen
side pawns up which should be white's
plan in the long run i love the move a6
i'm more worried that jake didn't think
of before and he just decided to play a6
i'm much more worried about that
freaking pawn was gone
so he wants to play this am i missing
something here
nope so he's is there anything tricky
here going on i have to take it right so
obviously i have to take it
nothing can block
is there something he's tricking he's
doing something tricky here
good call to take with a knight not
training queens yep does he have my mind
to attack
you just wanna keep the queens
i know on eyes aren't seeing the whole
border now that's not good
you just helped me develop i think that
was actually a very helpful move
absolutely right
[Music]
and 92.
this pawn striker is pretty good here i
push this pawn up is the question
h5 would be very good here
once again you started the pawn position
absolutely necessary sometimes i take
here
yeah this might be the highest level
opening we've seen in pogchamps
i think the best part of all this is
that jake jake and uh fiber probably
just like came up with all this
themselves
so that's even more you know respect
yeah
absolutely i mean they diverged early
from theory f65 and jake is thinking
about taking the bishop which you know
i've talked about this before i think
when you're new to chess even if you
know all of the basics it's very hard to
keep the tension when you see a capture
you kind of want to make it to clarify
the position i think a lot of players
don't like it when there's a lot going
on there's a lot of chaos so i think
that's why jake is thinking about going
e4 or knight takes two three both of
those moves sort of reduce the tension
on the board i don't know what you think
about that anymore bishop d6 though the
oxford developing
yeah i mean i like this development move
but what i've i'm always more worried
about right is the fact that like hey
whether you're playing knight takes g3
or whether you take on d4 at the end of
the day all those moves are kind of give
you the same evaluation to the position
it's all about equal
so that's a bit it's a bit worrying when
you spend that much time per move
because
it is only a ten minute plus five second
game and yeah and only 11 moves have
been played
only 11 moves have been played they've
been playing grand master level chess so
far
pretty much
yeah but i i can totally smell a time
scramble here and c4 adding some tabasco
sauce
or something with morse global units to
the position e4
by five up which is a pretty crazy move
it explodes the center
and i don't even know what's going on
jake could take the pawn on d4 he could
take the pawn on c4
probably from an objective
perspective it's not the greatest move
if jake takes
the pawn on d4 but this is going to make
him think
yeah this will whenever this decisions
it's it gets a little hard oh knight to
b4 okay opting to not take
on any of the either just yes yeah
just going to give the queen a little
bit of an attack and see where the queen
goes so
it's always good to give your opponent
threats i mean this makes your opponent
think too and makes them spend their
time
yeah where to put the queen i think
queen b3 or queen c3 would be the most
active i have a feeling
five up might be tempted by queen b1 in
order to keep an eye on the knight which
is not that important but
uh queen b3 would would sort of maintain
the pressure on on black's pawns but
you're absolutely right queens
can't go anywhere else it really hurts
me physically
not that i see at
least hurting physically
he also lost i was defending or
attacking this pawn
one crazy tactic
if jake takes dc
the knight will leap out onto what's
like over here and white will be
threatened that's a cheeky move this is
a cheeky move hold on a second i kind of
like that cheeky move
it just gets it gets into space
he has time to hear
and then
oh this is so good oh this is so good
wait hold on a second pause
wait that's such a good news to move
though
yep oh i want to like look at chat but i
also have it hidden because i want to
see reactions to the oh
whoa
whoa that is a very creative move by
jake it does matter yeah i think he did
see um five up having the opportunity to
play five so he plays c5 himself
people have their advils at the ready
look at those puns what's going on
white could take three different pawns
here white could take dc cd or d i think
white should probably play dc in order
to open that e file because if you not
notice the queen and the king
nema they're aligned and if white takes
dc and then cd
black could end up losing that bishop on
c5
yeah there's a lot of captures coming
through here and almost all of them
working white's favor
so
it's a little bit worrying i mean yeah
do take c5 like donya said and then
bishop takes c5 c takes d5 we got the
pin
on the c file and the king is still kind
of open so there's a lot of uh
oh
you split d take epa i think he sees
that he can win a pawn
in this case
but black can actually take the bishop
first that's a very high level
intermediate move and then take on e5
will jake see that
yeah taking the bishop first means that
there's no protector on the pawn and
then you can take with the bishop so
he's calculating let's see if he comes
up with the one thing we didn't want to
happen right
that five minute studies just back
[Music]
and he still takes this
he's in a pretty good position how that
music seems less calming now
it's got a little bit more hype
four and a half minutes
on his block
take that bishop
[Music]
oh no he's not taking the bishop he
hasn't gone that far with his tactics
yet
the whole lot of terrible he's gonna do
this and force them to take
for sure
the time honestly concerns me a lot more
than the material loss especially
all right anything not protected
and black is doing fine
the good thing is that he's always
looking at what's protecting what's not
protected that is at least good oh
absolutely he's playing very well 93
jumping in there with his knife
going for this free pawn maybe
i move this out i got to get this guy
involved right here
okay
not bad queen back to c3 here for five
up
would be the best move the only move
mm-hmm i guess he could pay for five two
i'm always just a little bit worried
when the night like moves so far up and
it gets a little bit difficult to um
you know defend your pieces
i'm so nervous man this chess game is so
bad
i'm also nervous mcqueen is saying
though from the other side
because yeah this is true there's a lot
of things to be worried about honestly
and jess how do we how do people even
play the game
it's constant stress
and you know what else i'm worried about
uh-huh
is a knight landing on v6 i don't know
i sound like a broken record i'm worried
about this night that i've just
highlighted and this square that i've
just highlighted
and then worried about a knight landing
there
yeah
at least we don't lose a knight and five
up doesn't lose his queen but
this does leave
the pawn structure a little bit
weaker on black's end and you know also
down a whole pawn so
yeah and now if you take on d5 with a
knight then you drop another pawn so
black should probably take with the
queen
and that would hit the knight on d2 and
that knight would probably come to c4
and
you know then white will be threatening
a fork
so
boo and e4 immediately
by five up which looks like a fork but
now the knight on d2 is hanging
so potentially this could lead to a big
trade i don't think five up saw
that the knight on d2 is hanging i
actually wonder if he did
let's see
i think he missed it but he now he sees
it
well the good news is even that knight
is hanging out even light still has
queen takes c5 is it more than
so i could have done this will jake see
that knight
so what he can do is he takes this i
would have to take this then he would
take this then i would take this then he
would take this
but then he loses the knight in the end
so
he should not be the one to trade queen
takes on each other this is not the
first c5 is the right way to go because
then yeah
and then everything you might see
that you have queen digs before at the
end
that's the line that works just fine
here
for why but it is a little bit difficult
to find oh queen d3
oh if i go here
um what's he trying to do here
there has to be a tactic for me
that's a weird move
that's interesting i have a checkup
i have a check into taking this
oh
now it's not as bad as it may seem
fake could that have been a mouse slip
it's possible
it's very hard to say no matter what i'm
losing this uh piece or this one i think
yeah white's probably not actually
winning a piece or not both one of the
white sides are hanging
that's the other solution
um this position is uh interesting now
very interesting i need to make sure i
don't lose here okay so i check him
he he does something it doesn't really
matter what he does
i could take either that or that then he
will take this or this
and then that leaves this open for him
here
but i have these two like i shouldn't be
worried
i'm gonna do
this
excellent i'm pretty sure this is fine i
think taking this one is better just
because i can retreat to here
and if he goes
here oh and now we can take the night
with track okay well this is another
channel
always remember to look at your checks
captures and threats
okay king moves up
this is another check
oh
now he's super confident
yeah
i like how he just goes for the checks
funny thing is both nights are hanging
so it's not over yet
well this is another challenge there's
one more check here oh
do i want to do this check not great
is this trade queens
this is a queen trade
and i'm up a piece
then he takes that with his
okay hold on
is there another tactic i can do
potentially
this gets the queen out that gets that
out
i think a queen trade is in store
i think i think it's just my best move
cause like i can't figure out like what
i'm supposed to do otherwise
yeah it was really hard to figure out
what to do instead
i still have this pawn forward
oh
no
oh my
alexandra
her your spirit is in this commentary
what have you done oh my god
this is so bad now
i can't trade for anything here
oh man
it was going so well just had to take
the queen and then take the knight it's
okay
and black actually would have been
doing all right a couple pawns down
oh man and now the wheels come off
completely
uh he's dropping his knife
and now he's gonna drop the other night
okay so
just very very quickly as the game
window lines down and the king walks up
to c5 what should black have done in
this position
black should not have
oh my goodness nemo you know what i just
saw what i don't think this would have
happened knight c4 white could have
played knight c4 intermediate move
getting the knight out of square where
it's attacked
and then white keeps the extra knight
if you would have seen that i would have
fallen off my chair now obviously if
flight takes the queen
and black takes the knight
and black will win probably another pawn
and black
black stays in the game
but i mean five i fully believe if i
love tactical skills honestly i think he
might have considered it it would have
been a really good in-between move if
you if he's if you're always looking for
checks then that is the in-between move
that you should be like
i might be overstating the case but i
think if he would have seen that that
would have been one of the best
pogchamps tactics because if you rank
moves that are difficult to see seeing
an in-between move is
among the most difficult
kinds of moves they're easily missed
even at the grand master level you know
absolutely okay knight f3 check
and
okay for some reason
for some reason white took with a pawn
but it doesn't matter why it's up a
million pieces anyway
it's okay even though you can be up so
many pieces there's opportunities to
lose
it's never over
yeah it's never ever over it's never
over until checkmate
i feel like given the way five up has
been playing he seems very very
confident in his conversion
yeah um and stalemate is generally the
likeliest way that these games turn
around and here just black has too many
pawns
rook do you want doubling rooks he's
probably going to swing this rook up to
d8 would be my guess
there it is it's changing the rocks as
well when you're up material you
definitely want to be swapping off the
pieces
like a good russian school boy yeah like
a good russian schoolboy exactly you can
make your extra pieces shine
now knight f4 would be an excellent move
bringing the knight in but he's probably
going to give a check
but we'll see oh he's played it wow
oh
and that shows pretty high level of
understanding activating as you said all
of your pieces not letting any piece
fall asleep
incredible
technical conversion here for five up
and now rook d5 or knight t3
forcing the trade of the rocks
oh
this is a bit of a brutal game
now for jake
that was not the only time to do that
and we'll watch
five up with the finishing touches here
you still can't take this pawn
and jake might lose on time here
yep
this game has been a tiny thing it's a
little bit too much i think fortunate
about b4
brutal
okay i really don't want to stalemate
him by accident
where can he go
black also has pawns so it's very
unlikely
but good thinking nonetheless
night episodes
that's this is some great endgame
technique
just making sure that oh there we go
promoting the queen so much time all of
a sudden is it plus two is it ten plus
two
actually ten plus five but nothing
really matters here
i actually have never heard somebody
describe five seconds
just
not the fastest way
no
we're getting there we're getting there
we'll see a checkmate on the
board easiest here would be just a
ladder mate okay seven queen v8 you're
locked there again
i think he sees it yep
mm-hmm
this is checkmate
and he i like that he pre-moves queen d8
very confident and five of wins the
first game i got to say that nemo okay
your student got the first game
oh boy
yes where is chat now there we go he did
indeed
and jake he played really really well i
was particularly impressed with his
opening play knight ge7 not trading
keeping the tension castling it seems
like the wheels only came off when he
started creating
all of that tension on the queen side
but that's completely understandable
that was a very high quality game in my
eyes
absolutely i think they both played
really well
i mean jake obviously just slipped a
little bit on the tactics over there in
the middle game very complex position to
even get out of the opening so i can't
fault him at all five up played
absolutely amazingly well and i mean
jake just played great as well just you
know five up was a little bit better so
that happens in chess
it really does and guess what jake will
have an opportunity to avenge his loss
try to get this into tie breaks during
game two but first we are going to go on
a quick break when we come back
game two of the matchup between jake and
bacon five up coming right up
why was this better
i still don't get it
whatever we'll figure it out
wait
why was this better
i feel like this sucks for me okay i'll
never understand that not immediately in
like two minutes
oh boy
that was bad i was so happy about this
move no
i guess i could have taken that huh
i could i could have still taken it
i was still fine though
oh wait no this is best move okay good
but then i give up
oh it's because they want me to protect
my queen i see fair enough
it's a missed win
me
okay i'm not mating in six i don't know
how to right now um
hi chat
we
did you when i wasn't paying attention
amazing comment
ah okay
i feel more comfortable but also like
it's a different type of stress because
you get to see what type of like i'm
used to playing versus fundy like fundy
and i just both play quick
bundy and i go like zoom um
so like he felt stressful to play versus
because he seemed like he was very
methodical in taking his time with
everything
but maybe he got in his own head
but i'm undefeated so far
okay
yesterday was definitely like 10 times
worse though
i'm also trying to like because i know a
lot of you guys don't know how to play
chess for the first part no funny is
better than me at chess right now but
i'll still win the tournament um
a lot of you guys don't know that like
the extended chat so i try to explain my
thought process for um
like what i'm doing so you can
understand do i have another match i do
have another match
yeah i'm trying to like at least explain
my
i'm a very amateur and like a very
amateur level when it comes to uh chess
welcome back to cog champs four
bachchamps is presented by coinbase earn
crypto by learning about crypto with
coinbase earn visit coinbase.com chess
and get five dollars in bitcoin when you
sign up and verify
your account
all right we are watching the first
matchup between jake and bake and five
up
five up playing a very confident game
with the white pieces winning in london
but nemo
it was very very close and jake with the
white pieces
i'm certainly not considering this match
to be anywhere near over
absolutely i mean i think jake
has a lot of potential you just
sometimes have to spot the right move
right it's just
you know chess at this level is a lot of
trying to find the piece you should
capture very specifically and it's
sometimes a lot of a 50 50 about which
piece you should capture or what you're
thinking the intuition is there
unfortunately there's not a limited time
but you know let's see let's see how
jake does this game
what do you think he's going to play is
it going to be a ooh and he's taking
some time on the first move here
hopefully he's aware the game has begun
i think he tends to forget
he he has done this before
he has not realized yet that his game is
off
yeah i think he's
deep in analysis
relax actually he would take a night
probably is better for him
i don't know
no maybe not actually
here here
here
opens up a lot of moves for me actually
holy crap
he just doesn't need the time you know
like he's very confident
badge
but i like that he's handling there we
go
uh all right let's go uh emo only please
now he's locked in
all right
actually we looked at bishop c4 but this
is what i prefer more so i'm happy
i'm perfectly happy high level opening
absolutely
and bishop c5 that is a move
castles excellent response
f6
he's being a little bit more quiet
this time around
but he's remembering all of the all the
expert opening analysis that he did with
his coach
yes he's dedicating every available
part of his brain c3
that is a classic rylopez move preparing
d4
i'm actually really surprised that he he
got everything down i'm super proud now
i did not explain to him what happens
after knight takes e4 so this part is
the part he has to figure out on his own
it is technically not a great move for
black
because you get a lot of compensation
for it but you do have to be really
careful
yeah d4 here would so the point is that
again it's all about peace alignment if
you notice the night in the king they're
aligned d4 would have opened the center
and then
later rookie one would have created
pinning chances but d3
that's not a terrible move but it chases
the knight away and that knight on e4
was actually vulnerable you don't really
want to chase it away
so now
even like d6 or knight f6 i think five
up is probably tempted with knight takes
f2
i can almost guarantee you that he's
thinking about it
but he's probably just gonna go back
yeah
i mean this is one of those positions
where it's like you couldn't play rick
d1 where p1 is also a very common
response in these positions followed by
d4
so for white to play d4 straight away it
might make a little less sense when you
don't already have a rook on the e file
but you know that's the beauty of
learning openings you understand a lot
of these concepts a lot of these ideas
and
toronto
there's a lot of layers like you learn
the standard moves but learning how to
react
to unexpected
lines that's one of the just one of the
hardest things to do you have to really
understand the opening knight back to f6
and white would still i would still go
d4 if i try to open up the center
because if he plays bishop g5 for
example or makes another developing move
that would relinquish the initiative and
allow black to castle
so nothing terrible has happened yet
and a lot of potential and i like these
positions kind of because it gives black
the opportunity to make mistakes and
sometimes you don't really need material
if your opponent runs the risk of like
making a bigger mistake so
right and ponds are not
i agree with you i think pawns are just
not a big deal in pog champs
i agree
on champs i think you can i mean two
three pawns down i don't even think of
the position as being clearly defined
and queen to e2
can immediately d6
now d4 would be even stronger using that
pin but bishop g5
focusing on the development
and fiber is just right
these are professionals
let's have a listen
he continues developing accurately
i think i'm down upon here still let me
double check this
i mean he wouldn't trade this he
wouldn't do that he goes here then i
just take
he takes
you put me in a weird position my good
sir
bishop g4 would be really good here
takes
i take
he has to move his queen what if i do
this
it's a solid move
it's a great movie i can't go here
anymore i have to boot this bishop
wow
really on the ball here i just realized
that it could have been very bad
i still i can do this still i have to do
this move first
you can also take this and open up that
which is still not terrible for me
not to
okay so that was the idea of knight of
c4
developing that night out
threatening potentially it might be time
for him to leave
hmm
i don't want to open this pathway to him
yet
i think it might be time for this guy to
leave
we'll do one move before that
now knight d5 as you said would be super
strong
he hasn't really thought of that idea
not sure if jake sees it though but
knight to d5 would be crazy here
um just
completely threatening black's kingside
right if you are forced to take on oh
oh my goodness he has that arrow that
was not my arrow
that's his arrow
he's gonna play it
will he play it
he will play
okay
you're a student nemo and he's not
saying anything he's locked in
he is his eyes fully focusing
i like this
i mean i also really like it when he
tells us every single thought he
possibly has going on in his head but
this is also good this is not bad at all
so just he's played c4 knight t3 knight
d5 i love it when we see
play that's this methodical
he had a plan he went with it
and now
five up i'm pretty sure it's probably
getting nervous
there's nothing he can do against the
destruction of his kingside fund
structure it's not a huge deal
but it's unpleasant
it's a rather i mean maybe i talk more i
don't know
kind of watch what he's doing here yeah
there's a lot of we all we both have a
lot of plays here i think um
i kind of want to get this pond
developed a little bit more
i don't even want to rook out here
i want him to take my knight real bad
that's not going to happen uh
[Music]
he's really thinking i like this i like
this a lot
the concept of the broken king side is
one that he knows well because i did it
against him and he learned
there's no better way to learn than to
have it done against you
absolutely and he's got the time
advantage here
what should black do here black should
probably just ignore what's going on on
the king's side but that's very hard to
do i think
um okay knight d4
so that causes
quite some chaos on the board white
should just take this knight and then
reposition the queen to f3
and hit that knight on f6
with even greater intensity
it is rather difficult to
have those concepts in mind though as
you're like playing this position you
might be thinking if i trade off my
knight well then am i like giving up a
little bit of tension am i giving a
little bit pressure so
i'm a bit worried about what jake might
play in this situation but what donya
said is absolutely correct
gotta take that knight the e takes d4 is
not a big deal even though your queen's
under attack you can just move your
queen to the side you don't have any
other hanging pieces and that knight is
still pinned
that's right but he might also be
tempted one of those temptations is to
take on f6 first
and that would actually be really really
bad
even though it doesn't blunder the queen
it's checked black plays she takes f6
and then white's got several pieces
hanging at the same time
and i'm i'm really worried that
jake might think well let's take that
knight first
see that it's check and not fully
recognize the repercussions of that
yeah
because uh but definitely he should take
them out
let's okay
we'll see where he moves
we always have this which forces this
whole situation to happen
okay he has taken tonight the pawn or
bishop
his pawn
now queen f3 is really strong
keeping pressure up on that f6 knight
it's pawn to create another threat on
the queen
all right
jake just has to find one move
yep and objectively white would almost
be winning there
is jake looking at it
is he thinking about it let's swing on
over
his cursor
[Music]
the cursor was on f3 and then they moved
away this bad boy now
now c6 wins a piece for black but that's
not easy to see
ooh
if he moves his queen out at all i have
a perfect little four key here for the
rooks
so queen comes out i have a
fork you can't move this right now you
can chase me
you can move this here
[Music]
pretty pretty good i think
if he does that i wouldn't leave that
effect here
wait no
[Music]
maybe i don't know
he's here i move here
[Music]
rook e6
trying to defend that night
[Music]
not easy to figure out what to do here
for white
nothing
oh nothing good there let's just move
this out
still giving up that for something
really important right now
i feel like he was bouncing over every
single goodbye and then decided to chuck
all of that out the window
yeah i mean i still think that if black
doesn't see the move c6
um then white is doing really well from
a conceptual point of view rick e1 is
actually very impressive he's bringing a
piece into the game
he's hitting that rook on e6
really to me the key question is will
black see
t6 and then if white plays knight takes
f6 both bishops will be hanging oh here
he takes i go here
he's fine
oh wow there it is
we haven't seen
it
that is impressive
and i also get this like untrapped so to
say because this thing is now the worst
uh bishop in the game
um how much time is left five versus
five
like what what i've done here is i've
forced this
and then the question becomes
do i want to
do this one or do i want to do this one
like what is more valuable to me is it
not trying to have an open file
because right now when i take this thing
um my queen will be open to this type of
attack and this file is open too i think
i
in a weird world i think i actually give
up my rook
which sounds really sus
oh
i feel like a lot of i guess the other
option would have been for me to move my
king instead of my rook
oh oh ah
whoa
whoa did we just hear that
go back go back
this is better
because what does he do he does this
which opens this file i don't think he
takes with this thing though
yeah i think i'm fine
doing this wow i think that's oh okay
so i have this
and if he does this i take with queen i
don't take with rook i'm fine
you see that the other bishop is hanging
is my question
he is doing much more than fine in this
position in case you are wondering if
the king is any kind of weak it is but
also
being up a piece is pretty darn good so
you know that kind of makes up for the
weak
weak king structure
yeah and black has a lot of pieces near
the king i think i honestly think that
he wasn't aware that the bishop is
hanging
and he was more focused on not giving up
the e-file which if you put yourself in
his shoes we talked about it when
there's a lot going on
um it's very easy to lose sight of one
or more important factors in the
position the fact that he's thinking
right now tells me that he's just not
seeing the bishop
he just needs to look at the queen side
yep
will
you pay attention to the queen side
yeah well i i always like to joke that
now the castle is less of a casa and
more of a barn that's like my go-to joke
whenever the pawns get a little bit
ruined on that side of the board but i
mean the barn is not all that bad you do
after taking the light square bishop you
still have all the opportunity to move
your king onto h8 and then you know
just avoid any checks in general because
white is down that one piece
yeah he finally took the bishop and now
white should probably just swing the
queen at h6 objectively as you
pointed out definitely white doesn't
have any sort of attack but
there's a big difference between
objectively and what happens in a pog
champs game
and why you should definitely
marshal the troops as quickly as
possible into that king side there is
always the opportunity of queen to h6
rick takes e6 and bishop takes f6
so there is the chance that g7 can be a
weak square and you might get checkmates
there
yeah there's all sorts of geometric
patterns whenever you have a bishop
first of all that's a line to the queen
and the bishop that's hitting the f6
spawn but
he's down at three minutes
i think he also he might be tempted to
take that pawn on b5
it's easy to
kind of miss the track of what's going
on
let's see
look i want to protect this line
from this
he needs to think a little bit more
aggressively when you're already down
material your best shot is just go for
checkmate and go all in
[Music]
yeah he's slipping a little bit here
not sure what to think about
but chess is a hard game i mean it's so
difficult too he's only played like four
games of chess you trade out rooks
he's been really impressive
i don't know dude oh no never mind he's
going to move with this
yeah much time on that move
[Music]
not the move i would have wanted to see
i don't think he saw that his queen can
go to h6 i don't think he has the idea
of the checkmate in his mind that's the
heart another hard part right is if you
don't know
that there's a mating net there
then i'll move this here
yeah if you don't see the pattern it's
hard to come up with it queen f8 is
great
wow
really stopping queen to h6 that is
impressive
[Music]
so he unpinned there
yep
[Music]
he's also down to
under two minutes
not looking good for mr jake
[Music]
rookie four
yeah that invites a rookie trying to
bring his work out though i think
i lift his truck to g4 i kind of like
the spirit of what he's doing
i just removed this from the equation
it does it does
hang a pawn
no it doesn't he was not going to take
it
why why would he move here what does
this do oh it's to check me
wow and he even identified the idea
wow fiber is just very impressive when
it comes to chess
super important yeah he really writes
intuition and everything i'm just there
there's no way i'm letting anything slip
by queen g7 is amazing just defending
everything
he might
he might be one of the favorites just
i haven't seen any of his games before
but like i don't have to play perfect
chess i just have to play better chess
than my opponent and make sure they
can't take advantage of something like
all that matters and chess is just
winning it's beating the opponent it
doesn't necessarily matter how good you
play as long as you win
you just call that clean even if it's
like you score like three on accuracy
at least that's how i think about chess
in uh in tournaments
and um if i'm playing casually
i'll want to play to improve in
tournaments i'm going to play to make
sure i win
he is a minute left versus three minutes
i have given him he has no checkmate
concepts at all i have my king perfectly
defended even though i stacked this
so i'm fine
and there's no way i can stalemate him
yeah it's a little early to talk about
stalemate
i like the just win strategy though
that's the favorite my favorite piece of
advice i give to beginners they're like
how can i get to x
for y rating i'm like have you tried
just winning i know right
queen four is nice
but even if that pawn falls
the queen just
gets to g6
[Music]
okay
i don't know why i did that how do i
prevent
oh my god
that was really that was a very bad
mistake by me
oh okay hold on oh my god he's
gonna blow he's bloody evil oh my god
he's losing everything
oh no oh god this is the definition
this is the definition when it starts
going bad it goes really bad this is
like the perfect metaphor for life when
one bad thing happens it's just a train
wreck yeah it's the domino effect
oh no
but white's queen was so close too and
he was so confident and he didn't
it
and it was like a weird delayed reaction
i almost feel like he didn't
react as emphatically as one should
yeah here's here's the concerning thing
though nemo
if black plays rook f6 right now
and then white takes on d3 and black
takes on f2
um there will still be some back rank
made possibility so now it's
now it's the wild west i i don't even
think this is necessarily winning for
one i just like to say this is a coin
flip i love calling the game
yeah
well let's see what joe is thinking he's
and then force him to move
uh-oh
oh
are we gonna see what danya said oh
oh my
okay now the bishop steps back it
creates a mate threat
[Music]
but white comes first
just don't get check painted oh
do not take that bishop
no don't take the bishop
my god
wow
took the bait holy i should have
checked him
that was actually so good bait dude
i'll take that loss that's the only loss
that felt good in chess so far
that's good dude oh my god
that was a good loss
holy crap
oh my god what did we just see
and here's the thing rook g3 was
literally basically checkmate because
if the king walks to f8 it's mate
if the king goes to h6 it is checkmate
but nemo
this is what a move bishop d4 is debate
and
i'm going to vote
that our play of the game
presented by eternal.gg
goes right here to that last moment
bishop to t4
offering up the bait
and jake he was too confident after he
won the queen he grabbed that bishop
quickly
and he allows
checkmate on f1 backrank mate is such a
big decider of pog champs games
oh my lands emo what a crazy moment and
well
five up definitely did the just win
strategy
he definitely you know just like yeah i
don't need my queen i don't need any of
my pieces i just need to win i mean
he managed to make that work for him so
insane well
if you think display deserves to be
internalized
make sure to sign up on eternal.gg with
your twitch account and type eternal all
caps in chat to vote the play of the
games that receives the most votes will
be turned into digital collectibles and
dropped on september the 12th with all
proceeds going to red our charity
dedicated to making mental health
accessible
three lucky viewers who voted will win a
free pack and we will announce the
winners and
now you can pre-order the pock champs
four pack containing epic moments from
this tournament including those voted
for by you limit of three thousand packs
three packs per user sign up now with
your twitch account and watch out for
more info on voting to turn play of the
game into eternal packs that you can win
oh my goodness what did we just see this
is pogchamps at its finest
and
the best news is that we have two more
matchups to go and if there's anything
as interesting as this one
well we want to make sure everybody
keeps their seat belts buckled their
coffee cups refilled
and we will do the same we will be back
in just a few
with a post-match interview we'll get
these players thoughts on the other side
of this break
it's it's it's fine guys look he's
playing the the the the brazilian grass
ball
he's playing the brazilian bulbasaur
don't worry we're gonna be okay
we're gonna hit him with the cleveland
charmander we're gonna clap his
cheeks don't worry bat bat i'm telling
you right now it's very underrated in
malaysia but today we're about to make
it popular this will be the new meta you
don't want to do this kid
you don't want to do this take my pawn i
will kill you
i will kill you i will
massacre you you don't want this you
don't want this heat bro
okay let me tell you i don't make moves
okay
you come at me i will lock us up i don't
i don't make moves that is not my job
that is not my job
but you need to back the up before
i punch you in your throat
i kill you every day of the week here
try it
see what happens idiot
go ahead move your horse
yeah back up dumbass
what you gonna do huh better get your
cheeks clapped
go ahead my only weakness is queen place
and no yeah that's right back up
try again
try it back up
back up
damn right
you're damn right
back the up boy
all right uh
hold on we going we about to go the long
way
the are you doing you crazy ass are
you stupid
are you dumb you know what you did
yeah now what boy
thanks for the horse
idiot
try again
try again see what happens
i will strike you down with
swift
and vengeful justice you're lucky i
don't know how onpassar works
otherwise i'd beat the out of you
what does that even do what are you
threading my pawn oh my god i'm shaking
in my custom seal leather boots hold up
pause gamer
uh-huh
yeah
if i just take that what does he do
nothing yoink
okay and then you don't got nothing
you have nothing
and now i'm
why'd you do that
oh
you're not taking my back you can take
it if you like
and that's what you hold up
thanks
new boots new boots
if i go here he
on passants right that's fine right hold
up yo do the umpassant thing
shoes thank you boy
now we opened up like a fresh watermelon
uh i can't do about that uh but if
i do
watch this 23 skidoo bro he's not going
to see it coming
yoink
i don't even want that that piece
sucks
hey that's really
shhh
why'd you do that
wait stop
wait no
wait no i don't like this hold on what
do i do this
[Music]
oh you put me a check wait stop
what are you gonna do
okay
all right sir
wait no wait hold up stop
wait stop look at this
welcome back to pogchamps 4 presented by
coinbase and we are joined by the two
gladiators jake and bake and five up
five up congratulations on an excellent
match jake we were so impressed with
your play even though the match
shouldn't go your way in the end uh do
you feel like you uh applied some of the
lessons from your first match against
ludwig if so what were they and how did
you feel throughout this match
um yeah actually i felt a lot more
confident this match i trained a little
bit more i played more games played on
time which was my biggest problem with
ludwig and i also trained a little bit
also with chessweeb too which helped me
um
i actually felt super conf a lot more
confident and like i felt like i played
better which it felt nicer during the
games and like at the end game in the
last game like i felt pretty confident
going in
but
just my eyes aren't looking out for
everything i need to look out for i
think it just comes with time like i
just need to play more and uh dude that
that outplay like i said it right away i
don't know if you caught it but i was
like dude this is
i'm okay losing to this because it's
like
i will 100 learn from this and it's like
dude the puzzles paid off and like you
know i could tell like dude that was i'm
okay for that it's like damn all right i
deserve that loss that's that's fine but
i'm feeling a lot better like overall
about it
that is good to hear that is good to
hear
yeah and um
no we were
you came so close to winning that second
game and uh but five up you're an
absolute beast
uh
especially that first game and your
conversion as well
five of you were referencing i think
some of your past experience uh could
you tell us a little bit about sort of
when you got into chess and how your
past experience has helped you so far in
pogchamps
oh
i think you're muted
i was muted the entire time uh
i've been i've been playing chess ever
since i was little and it was more of
been like an on and off thing but back
when i was like in like on sixth grade
fifth grade somewhere around there i
used to actually be in the chess club
and i competed in tournaments every so
often and then just fell off from there
and just recently got back into it
besides like every so often the casual
game um
so i do have like the memories of oh
yeah there's like these fun tactics you
can do i just don't remember how to see
them um but that has helped me a lot and
it's more
i wasn't able to train that much because
i was gone
but it's more bringing those memories
back so that's why i think i can go a
little bit even with the people here um
but yeah i play chess for
like getting better unless it's a
tournament then i just try and win
whatever means possible as you saw here
yeah i think we really liked your sort
of monologue about you know how to just
win and how to approach a tournament and
then the next movie blunder your queen i
really like oh no
but you still didn't just win strategy i
mean at the end you baited jake with a
bishop checkmated him so how are you
feeling actually after giving that
entire monologue and then you're like oh
like
i feel uh embarrassed that i feel like
it was fitting at least i mean i gave a
good example i mean that's what i really
need to do at that point
yeah you did definitely set a very good
example for
just winning
yeah
yeah i'm gonna have nightmares about it
but nope we're good
and uh you've got a match against ludwig
uh i believe who is of course
the vc the final boss uh how do you feel
about that match five up and uh
are you gonna go on all guns blazing
uh yeah i mean he's been taunting me
saying hey stop practicing so i can beat
you so i already feel like he's nervous
uh so i feel like i have a good chance
against him uh the goal is to go
undefeated overall
i'd be saying how it is
wow okay we have some high aspirations
oh 100
all right this is gonna be exciting i
wish this was double elimination because
i'd come back you know i come back i
swear
ghosts of the past
i have faith in you jake i believe in
you
look i'm telling you i think i played
ludwig and five up first this is like i
played with donuts on the bat these are
my training wheels these guys are
weighing me down like they're they were
hard i had to fight past even see the
surface and now that they're out of the
way it's like dude you know it's i don't
know i'll see if i go to that
constellation bracket and see how i can
see how i can do i'm coping real hard
it's all good you had some amazing games
you had the perfect opportunity to beat
five of today um
it just could be anybody's game you
never know what might happen so yeah
good stuff
definitely no if you play like you did
today i think you've got a great shot
and five uh best of luck to you against
ludwig thank you to both of you for uh
for your time and and for the awesome
match and and the interview
thank you so much and thank you did you
see that
crazy good luck
all right
bye
what a match
it was between five up jake and bake
they both of course will hold their head
up very high five up with a tough match
against ludwig well we've got the second
match coming up but first we want to
remind you that chess.com is very happy
to be supporting rise above the disorder
rad
in their cause to remove the two
greatest barriers to mental health care
access and affordability started by a
world of warcraft guild leader in 2013
rise above the disorder has helped tens
of thousands of people all over the
world receive mental health care free of
charge one go to
go.chess.comrad to make a donation and
remember just.com will be matching up to
100k
of the communities contributions
all right
crazy match nemo and hopefully we have
an equivalently crazy match
coming up are you excited for this
second match i am super excited i can't
wait to see both of these players do
their best performance and play their
best chess it'll be very exciting
indeed first we're going to go on a
quick break don't go anywhere on the
other side of the break we'll have qt
cinderella and tech tone duking it out
we will be right back
good luck on the match today thank you
thank you thank you i don't feel super
prepared i just haven't been sleeping
well so
oh thank god i just tested this
any thoughts on hikaru's snubbing pog
champs
you want my take on chest drama
uh
i didn't know that was a thing
thank you
thank you i know i'm a gamer
i know
because i operate under pressure
[Music]
dude just wait till i take you the sip
of this advanced gg bro
just white
i'm a freak of nature
not keep it in emote only mode
keep it in emote only mode you
moglet
thank you
feeling good
i can do that again
congrats max valley ave today you were
the worst man
congrats
congrats my brain is operating on levels
that the human consciousness cannot
comprehend run it back let's go
[Music]
yup
come on yep
yep
do it i dare you
i dare you
i dare you step to me i'll break your
jaw you'll be sipping fried chicken to a
crazy straw
peep this camera guy
give it to me
oh you thanks for the free
bishop you nerd
oh i swear to god i'm gonna strike you
down with swift and unrelenting justice
white you're trying to kill me
stop that
he's gonna get my bishop for freedom
that sucks
that's not the play that was not it that
was not the play i'm scared for my life
chad i am scared for my life
i should have just
[Music]
rise above the disorder
come on come on hey i don't know if i'm
still on but i will continue i just hop
up on the stream and make my venue yeah
you know that i'm here just to elevate
hey your mental health is essential i'ma
tell them straight yeah hey yo don't
talk about it often but we gotta kill
this stigma cause we all deal with
problems yeah so this should be
something normal to converse about cause
everybody has mental health and we hurt
no doubt yeah anxiety depression got to
overcome i'd be on my job and i'm about
to get it done i'd be letting more
lyrics drip up off the tongue it's every
neck i'm shining like the sun i'll be
rhyming in the sash yeah times in my
life i've been depressed yeah at times i
felt just like a mess yeah but y'all
these types of organizations will get
you through the stress come on rise
above me we rise above it we
intercession for our cause and they love
it rising above it rising above it it's
everybody i can rhyme on any subject
welcome back to fox champs four that was
some awesome wrapping
rad theme rapping from harry mack and
nemo as we have a quick look at the
prizes that's some hefty sons that
they're playing for and we already know
all of the players are nervous you know
there's a lot at stake here pride and
quite a bit of money as well
yeah absolutely i mean
we do have 20 000
going to the winner in the championship
bracket
and the consolation bracket winner also
gets a hefty 7 000 so
don't forget even if you participated
each group stage winner gets 2 000. lots
of prizes
every single person here is going to be
a winner but some people are just more
winners than others so that's how this
works
indeed and we have yet to determine who
the winner will be in our second matchup
which is right about to begin we've got
cutie cinderella and techtone who i
think is already a crowd favorite after
his first match against nick a30
we are going to be tuning in to techtone
a lot because uh
let's just say he's um how should i put
it quite the
tucker and quite the character
oh my goodness oh my goodness we already
have a blogger as qt she developed her
bishop before her night
and now techtone can take that pawn on
g2 and trap the rook
but will he do it i think ptg didn't pay
attention to
how black developed his bishop first
let's listen i hate this guy
she saw it
that's genuinely not good so i've played
a few games where i've lost this pawn
early and then had to like
do some
because of this setup
now i don't
yo
yo yo
right now
i can guarantee he's going insane right
now i am not going to lose this for
every single person who thinks
i'm too stupid to play chess
because of me
tech tone standing at 275 pounds six
foot seven and the dumbest man alive and
even i
a complete
idiot can play this game your blunder
tactical do not blow this for the little
guys who think i can't do
it come on baby
oh how did i not say oh man
oh my god
it hurts how does that even happen
both
both are just gone both of them i block
you then what coward
thanks
plus one baby i'll check that as a dub
come on bro then what
then what
i'm speechless
i'm just speechless does that really
just happen
i can't believe it
[Laughter]
that yeah just happened did we really
just see both of the both the a8 and the
a1 rook just get captured off the board
in like the first 10 moves of the
opening
did we really just see that this might
be the first time in chess history that
in nine moves we have seen a trade of
the h1 rook for the a8 rook
and they're playing very very quickly i
mean qt
i like b3 bishop a3 she develops her
bishop very actively attacked on castle
so now they've somewhat stabilized
the reason i'd be worried about black's
position here is because of this bishop
on h1 which actually now is stranded and
qt has done an excellent job she played
f3 immediately to keep that bishop
locked in
wow but um
impressive
now i will tell you nemo what having
having seen tektone's first match
against nick
uh he was the better player but at many
critical junctures he simply played too
quickly
and a lot of his blunders were caused by
um well let's just say
banter not producing the greatest the
greatest moves in
stages then here for example he has to
avoid the temptation to move his knight
out
so a good move here would be rookie
eight
um or even a move like c5 or e5 trying
to open up the center but it's a hard
position to figure out what to do and i
feel like
he might be tempted by an aggressive
looking move like queen d5 that's how i
play okay he goes f5 no big deal easy
peasy
easy's in chat oh wait you can't see
easy's in emo mode
oh
all right we do see the f5 on the board
now that's an excellent move
because now that rook stares at the
bishop and knight h3 here
could win the bishop
all right he's got bam bam thank you sam
he takes there's a lot of things
happening here i need extra protection
there huh
she doesn't have fun
extra protection there
if he takes
i take
he takes
he takes i take i feel fine
this is there it is
okay
she's done it
that's great stuff from cutesy that
bishop on h1 is toast this is ugly chess
this is some ugly ass chess
let me tell you that
i actually like to say this is very
pretty it was very geometrically
pleasing that both of the rooks
disappeared off the board
and he did play queen d5 um i think tech
tone likes he likes aggressive chess
he's got good instincts but
man that was such a promising start and
now
he is simply a piece down
and this knight can come out to f4 and
chase the queen away from the center
yeah
cutie has just played playing very solid
now i like it
up a piece everything's protected
i have a feeling techtone
is probably referencing the brazilian
how do these people fight rainforest
defense good god
how do people even see that
what type of prescription goggles are
they wearing
well i don't know what to do you took my
bishop that was my whole game plan that
was frank
he wanted this dump so bad
and now they're going to move upon and
it's going to be intimidating
they're going to threaten my queen and
i'm going to look like a coward when i
have to move her back i don't know what
to do i'm scared what do i just what do
i just do this
is that a bad idea
[Music]
you're gonna try to kill my horse
i hate this
no i'm scared i give up
i'm scared i don't want to do this
anymore i always lost my horse
oh god
now i do it
take it
take it coward
i was told he said that's
scared baca
eden yeager
i go up i stay on the assault
i might be behind on pieces but i'm not
behind on hard
and that's what matters they say
techtone you may be the worst swimmer i
ever met but you got heart kid
hold on i go over here i can't take that
but i could pretend like i can i could
just move it up railroad fight the power
he takes it back what are you gonna do
back up kid what you got boy
huh
[Music]
i like this put that queen back
halt
what if i don't take on e3
is there like a mickey mouse play i can
play right here i think i should move my
pawn forward yes
yes certainly right i should just move
pawn forward right i move pawn forward
threaten the horse he can't take back
because of uh you know cooties and all
that organs go all the way up that
doesn't do anything there's played by
pawn louis right here that runs the
horse he goes there puts my rook in a
thing but then i just block it i feel
like that's just the play now am i am i
dumb yeah but is there another play i
could just take that with my pawn too
no no no no no if it goes there then i
just move there that's fine i'ma just
take this
we had the right move
we saw the right move
why do we not play the right move
he's not saying anything that's a bad
slide
oh my god
this is agony
oh my goodness
do you know it's sad when tech tone
doesn't say anything
and
cinderella that is just a
that is just uh
that is just thai g5 queen h4 straight
into h7 and nemo was one of those things
where
he saw the defense
i i don't understand because if he saw
h6 then
he probably understood why h6 was being
played
what happened there was some sort of a
misfire
i don't understand it
it's fine it happens i don't think he
actually saw queen takes h7 was
checkmate i think he just wanted to play
h6 he just wanted to chase the knight he
felt the pressure that white was
exerting but didn't deem it important
enough to deal with it right
it's not really important it's just
checkmate nemo stop making a big deal of
it yeah it's just christmas thank
goodness like well i i could just take
the pawn on e3 and you know it should be
fine it's cool it's cool we're just
taking pods well i think i need some
time to process that game and i think
everybody does so
we are going to go on a quick break
but when we come back we will have game
two between qt cinderella and tech tone
epic stuff on the other side of this
break
so my blunder was at the very beginning
of the game when i didn't see what he
was doing
sick not too bad
not too bad
i destroyed him i mean he's 300
underneath me i would
i would hope
i would hope i would destroy him
otherwise that'd be very embarrassing
i'm gonna try something i uh
uh
shouldn't do in the next game
i'm gonna try something i just think
it'll be fun
we're gonna see if it works
uh
what was the accuracy score
uh i don't know how to see that
i don't know how to see the accuracy
screwer
i am i'm gonna do a throwback next game
quick throwback
i'm gonna do something donya taught me
i had 45 accuracy i suck
don't leak
what do you think's happening you think
tekton is listening and he's like i know
what donya taught cutie
yeah he does for sure and he's like oh
i'm going to recover with this line i
know exactly what she's going to do
tech tone has been molding for the past
five minutes
he's fine he'll be fine
he's having a breakdown
flux cups thank you for the sub
listen
it's okay
sometimes you lose the video game i lose
this video game all the time
he just really wanted to win
it's fine
he called you a bully
i hope he drops out
why because i'm an idiot
damn it dude damn it
oh
there's no hope for me i give up
i quit i should have stuck to checkers
man
i should have detected checkers man
whatever
oh whatever man
there's got to be hope for me
is there any hope i hope to god somebody
here believes in me
because i don't
man you know it's like
i'm such a big fish in a small pond you
know like i clap all my buddies and then
i go to pog champs and they just make me
look like
they make me look like kilauea on the
chimera ant arc
pogchamps 4 is presented by coinbase
whether you're looking to make your
first crypto purchase or you're an
experienced trader coinbase has you
covered earn crypto by learning about
crypto with coinbase earn power up your
trading with coinbase's advanced
features get exclusive rewards when you
spend with coinbase card and much more
learn more at coinbase.com
chess
welcome back to fox champs 4 presented
by coinbase
and i don't think anybody
techtone might be the most unique person
on earth and he is currently facing off
against qt cinderella
nemo he's pumping himself up and he's
got a comeback
to make he needs to win the second game
with the black pieces to take it into oh
sorry with a white piece to take it into
a tie break
you have chances
yeah
i mean i think he has some chances if he
you know focuses on the game after his
opponent makes a mistake
but i think what happened in this game
was that he got the early
like lead he got the rook and it was
it's like yes now i'm winning
definitely definitely
slapped him back with the same tactic
and he was just like okay
well that happened so
oh i agree
he was just too i mean it is very
exciting when you win material early in
the game but it's also like you know
getting out to a 20-point lead in the
first quarter of a basketball game
there's all the rest of the pieces are
still around you can't relax
and tech tone
going for g3 he is a hippo player so
he's going to fianchetto both bishops
and then play d3 and e3 and get the
knights into e2 and d2 so
i think he does that every game for you
oh i'm so sorry
you didn't know he handles the opening
i have the stonewall that levy taught me
and then i have a different thing that
i'm not going to say what it's called
because i don't want these
google and for my secret weapon but
i have something that donya taught me
that i've been practicing practicing
practicing practicing like a psychopath
that i haven't been able to use yet
because i need the right opening for it
and maybe i can do it on a different
opening but
i'm not going to reveal what it is um
i see how it is i'm supposed to
get this guy out
in a boat
excellent play bishop
and then you come out in a boat and then
you come out and about you come out and
about
and
yeah i think i could technically go here
but
i think he's knew enough of a player
that i'd get chased down i didn't feel
like moving my bishop a hundred times so
that's the only reason i didn't do that
she knows the slav
set up
is this secret opening
i was like be sick if i just went here
and then there then neither confirm nor
deny
um
okay welcome out
okay tech time is slowed down time to go
about
very solid development so far
and um okay he's doing some things
yeah i mean
the uh the hippo is not the most
dangerous
opening in existence it's not like you
play it and
white has any chance to win but from the
perspective of gems nemo i think
it's not a bad choice because you can
play it quickly
and uh it makes the opponent think
although qt is playing this very
confidently
i mean i like this opening just because
it just makes it like simple to play you
can't really mess up if you
you know just push your paws up one
square there's only so much your
opponent can do if you don't give her
something to attack as well
but i'm a little bit more worried about
what techno is going to do now after
he's pushed his pawns into the full
hippo structure what are his plans in
this position if i move my kingdom
pocket here i believe
i believe that's the play uh i could be
dumb
and i am
but here's why i'm less worried than i
was this round than the last round is
because this round i have more time than
her
and i heard somewhere probably in
chicago that time is money which means i
must be a goddamn whale i'm in my
environment
you go there i kill you from 50
different directions
like jariah
i'm sorry i can't help you
okay let's carry on this is so out of
context
we'll be okay
what do you think qt is thinking about
right now
i have no idea this this is the most
wacky positioning ever
you know mine's so nice and clean look
at this what is this mess
what do i want to do i just don't know
what i want to do
same girl same
i feel like you pushed the e pawn
i won the only time
all i can think about is changing the
music and i can't think of any chess
moves at the moment
um i go here there
there there well i don't want to go
there i can push this
he goes there
there's that
um
oh she's thinking about e5
[Music]
uh thank you for that prime
impressive stuff grabbing the center
i just need to get we got to get some
trading happening i'm considering this
trade but i don't
really want to trade a bishop for a
night
and i was going to say tech tone my move
is
tactile loves this queen maneuver but he
forgot the knight was hanging
oh no
[Music]
and when he's not saying anything that's
a really bad sign nemo really bad
he seems a little
unhappy right now
that sucks
that sucks balls
that sucks balls dude i mean i saw him
do this queen maneuver god i did it
again oh god
oh jesus christ no it's okay it's also
just a prophet that's why he's known as
the dropping like that right
why i made oh
i thought i was doing good
where is this queen going
to move
from a one piece and then queen a1
oh
i'll be okay oh we can come back from
this
we're missing okay
was i really going to use it anyways no
problem on the next move after he pushes
the deep well
he's going to play d4 and then he's
going to play rook c1 i think and queen
that's the play baby that's the play
that's right back up kid
respect yeah he plays the same way
learn yourself something about him
i'm telling you just wait
just wait i'm about to eat you alive
i go here you kill me not a good play i
go there you kill me i go there you kill
me i kill you you kill me not good
are you following this calculation
i am
kind of the cursors are there
so i'm like kind of understanding that
he's just like thinking about
picks e4 probably and like or knight
takes e4 or something like that but
i need to make sure everybody knows he
plays the same way every single game and
he does this maneuver so
it's called the tommy pickles that's
what he calls it
the tommy pickles why is it coming
[Music]
um
i'm not sure i'm the greatest authority
on translating uh some of techtone's
phrases and giving you the etymology of
them
i think it's up there with the
brazilian there's definitely a brazilian
something but i don't know what it is
did creek court coach him he because
krieger is the only brazilian that i
could think of right now from
from coaching
it's actually it's possible but i also
think he comes up with names oh
really it was japanese
who coached tutor
on the hippo
and
i have to be honest and say i don't know
if the hippo every single game is gonna
work out the absolute best for you but
you do you techtone you do you we're
here to support you
we are and well guess what he's built up
a very nice battery that bishop on d4 is
on an outpost and an excellent move here
would be to push the sea pawn up to c4
uh because you know give this rook on c1
a job it's aligned with the queen and
even though he's a piece down
if he plays c4
i think that
uh he's going to be in pretty reasonable
shape all things considered
but um
i feel like he's
all right we'll see yes he plays c4 okay
i am impressed wow look at this no i
love c4 it's such a good move you know
you got to open up the center a little
bit
uh your rook's already on a huff if well
we'll be on an open file really soon and
if cutie ever tries to take on d5 after
you take on d5 then there's also a weak
g7 pawn so
you see with 95 let's see
her perspective
[Music]
oh
i just away my queen
that was pretty cool i hate myself now
[Music]
oh my god what is going on here black
has two rooks
no dude oh whatever i got your queen
oh but you took both my rocks
see my pop
uh
all right you should take the knight
here that's fine oh we're going is he
really into japanese culture like anime
and stuff we're good we're good don't
worry i'm like starting to understand a
little bit more we got this easy breezy
covergirl
no we win this i thought my queen queen
way better dude
way better for a player who's like an
idiot
yes you do that
for what i don't know but i'm going to
take your pawn now
how do you respond
and then he should push that pawn you go
there okay the the classic backup strat
all right what if i just move forward
now the
[Music]
you cannot take my pawn
you cannot and you will not
take the knight
what are you doing
why are you he's asking the right
questions but he's not making the move
yeah this is this this reminds us of
lost game a little bit he was seeing
how he was always saying the right ideas
oh and he actually does play around he
takes the knight okay but this is where
things gets off because he's got
he's he's got a knight
and a queen for two rooks
but um
he's gotta figure out a way to import it
let's see what he's thinking
if i lose it's genuinely lily peach's
fault
will cancer her on twitter
it's never my fault for just like not
looking at the board
um
[Music]
so he has to take
then i take and i got that again
that's all i'm waiting for
[Music]
that cone should get his knight into the
game and i'm feeling moved by bounty
because he might keep pushing his funds
[Music]
five and a half minutes
h4
would be attacked until
would love if we went just a little
faster oh look at him go
home girl now the knight should go to d6
something about home girl i see
she's going to chase it now the knight
has to go to d6 otherwise
[Music]
otherwise you got to go back
and that's not what you want absolutely
definitely have fun
okay this is a big moment actually tech
tone down to five minutes he's not
usually in time pressure he plays fast
let's take a look you see
what is that wait
okay let's right
what was that
oh my god
okay that wasn't it
that was not it
no out of all the places i could have
done that wasn't it that was not it nope
that was not it that not that that was
the furthest thing from it
that sucked
oh that sucked ass
oh jesus christ
no oh my god i'm i'm i'm a troglodyte
jesus christ
come on techy you got to be able to
salvage this
there has to be a way to salvage this
dude i was so close to oh i was doing so
good
no dude come on bro
oh i'm ugly
what if i go
there
that's actually a pretty good move
danger levels i think that's a thing
because the thing is cutie should take
the knight
but it's it's very hard to move to play
because you're tempted to
move the rook but she takes off e5
that's
reasonable
we're gonna have a two rook for the
queen situation this might get wild
i kind of like this move because you
sort of have to take with the knight on
c4 so after knight takes d5 there will
be 65. let's see if cutie sees that or
is thinking about that
oh okay moves his king
and she immediately moves the rook
allowing knight
i have so many options here
black is better here but not by a lot
[Music]
like do i need stronger prescription or
how in the hell am i that blind to a
plate
that's that just happens
the fact that i didn't see that
oh my god
oh the great blunderfest of 2021.
let's go
all right oh it's coming up now get it
over with
okay
i hate you
i hate you so much anakin
oh
how do i come back from this i can't
unless you do something really dumb
which that would be pretty epic
that would be pretty epic if you did
something dumb
but i don't think you're going to
oh the stalemate loses no
no
no i had it i guess it loses the match i
just
so
hard
and give me checkmate
move this rock just for two seconds of
your life
move your rook
and just say oopsie whoopsie
you know it would be
it would be hilarious
how
do i get you
to just
stop being better than me
how do i do this
i'm gonna just move at random
just take it go ahead
i hate this guy he sucks
he's terrible
he's not a good friend
this pawn
he's he's a complete ass
come on
just take them
and just
wait why did you give me your pond
why did you do that
what does it all mean
why did you give me your pawn
i appreciate it
but why i'm gonna lock myself up here
real quick
okay i'm gonna just lock it up
how do i win
whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa
you didn't tell me my thing
let's go
thank you there's a chance there's a
chance there's a chance there's a chance
i can do this i can do this i can do
this i have two minutes
i got one free piece and that's all i
needed she didn't see it she got cocky
this is fine
you guys can't see us but donya is just
like
breathing you're just breathing that's
the only thing you can do right now he's
just breathing
it's stupid
he's just chilling he's crazy i also
have insomnia
oh my god rook f3 leads to a winning
pawn end game it forces white to give up
the queen
she's played it and tekton's gonna be
cursing himself but he doesn't see that
he can take the rook
does he
does he see that he could think
you know what i don't wanna go on
you have one piece of advantage on me
and unfortunately
this is the anime
head first i am scared of you i
push that
pawn take i don't want it
i can win this i can win this i can win
this one i can do this
i can do this
now she's gotta she's gonna have to stop
that pawn with her queen stop
this is a good endgame from cutie stop
stop
you right
no i can do this
come on techy
now what
wow she's playing this correctly
she's playing this incredibly correctly
king the element where i thrive
i'm charging right for you
you cannot handle that no no no no no no
no no no no
slightly unfair
these are some quality end games oh
straight out of portugal
damn it
[Music]
no
qt no
please we could have a beautiful
friendship
oh we could have been friends
i could have been there there's no way
this will be something right obviously
the chandler
you know i don't know still wins the
message
oh i don't know if he knows the mating
pattern though come on
can we just king v she doesn't watch key
right
that's all you need i mean that's all
you need
yeah okay let me just go back to that i
think i went over this checkmating
pattern with her
keep following the king in a night's
path get in your corner
go to your corner
[Music]
she knows it
she's gonna get there
[Music]
queen c7
with king b5
there's a chance that i this up and
he gets a sick um she knows it stalemate
but i doubt it
[Music]
but there's always a chance
oh my god
she's gonna bring her king in instead
and now queen slow and steady wins the
race right
getting indeed king in
i did it up literally like three
nights ago
[Music]
it was pretty funny
this is where stalemate becomes a
possibility so she's got to be very
careful
i can just see it in my head now f2 i
can do it
she's almost there
yep
any move wins what do i avoid okay i
might it up i'm feeling pretty
confused right now if i'm being honest
which will be funny it would be really
funny if i mess this up
there's no maiden two but this is
something about anybody with dyslexia
and chat and and tries to play chess
knowing that you have to go like certain
directions
really with your brain
because something about dyslexia is you
uh convince yourself it's something else
um
because you know the right one and the
wrong one and then you convince yourself
otherwise if that makes sense like uh i
do it with words all the time
uh like
omnis
is not the word omnius it's
is it omnius
i don't remember
okay i know uh this is the the last
squares of death
i know that
what you have to do is cut the king off
one more file
otherwise it's not going to be made
i go here
he can't go here he still goes there
i don't remember it queen before she's
repeating oh no
just don't repeat it three times
right
i don't remember any check is good i
actually don't
queen c3 is good
this isn't not right
i have a bad feeling that she's going to
move her king
i might
i might draw
yeah i'm struggling to remember i have a
really bad feeling she's going to move
her king to c2
do not move the king to c2
queen v4 is the best here
it's down here
please you know okay that's it all right
oh my god she got it you're gonna check
me aren't you
i know how this goes you're gonna
checkmate me aren't you
wow that was yes to me that was good
that was good that's some really good
stuff
and you know she took her time
um took a while and um
and she figured it out
exactly
nothing wrong with taking your time
gathering yourself and uh and pouncing
yep
sometimes that little you know the
spending that a moment of time when you
have time right before it's potentially
still made just thinking it through is
really important something everybody
here can learn probably because we've
probably all still made it
at some point
no absolutely we all have and man
there's a lot of competition for the
play of the game presented by
eternal.gigi i think a lot of things
could make the cut
but um
well
what am i going to point to i think the
queen blunder was crazy but since qt won
the match
um i think
you know what move i was very impressed
with um nemo was the fact that in in the
position after uh after techtone took
her bishop with that blunder rook g3
check king f2 and then seeing that the
pawn end game is winning and i'm just
going to put the whole
way that she played the end game under
our
uh play of the game and then in this
position rather than taking the pawn
boom she sees that she has to push that
pawn
uh the end game technique there nemo was
was excellent and that would be my vote
i fully agree with you that was some
good endgame technique
she probably read for uh varetsky so you
know good stuff for her no that was
excellent well if you think this play
deserves to be internalized uh sign up
on eternal.tg with your twitch account
and type
uh type eternal all caps in chat to vote
the play of the games that receive the
most votes will be turned into digital
collectibles and dropped on september
the 12th with all proceeds going to rad
charity dedicated to making mental
health accessible three lucky viewers
who voted will win a free pack and we
will be announcing the winners
and the future of fandom is here on
eternal.gg you can collect and trade the
best twitch and gaming highlights from
your favorite creators the same way that
you collect and trade pokemon cards ten
percent of all sales goes to supporting
the original creators and all proceeds
from poc champs 4 will go to supporting
rad
charity dedicated to
making mental health accessible great
stuff to be found on eternal.gg
and of course great stuff to be found in
this match we just saw between qt
cinderella and techtone which goes 2-0
in qt's favor what a match nemo and uh
no better way to capitalize to cap the
match than to listen to the player's
thoughts so we will have that in
uh we will have that for you right on
the other side of this break don't go
anywhere player interviews when we come
back
stop stop
so annoying
checkmate
okay
it's a baby and it's years old
all right
so that that that's that's that that's
the chess that's the chessing
um
do you understand everything about chess
now
awesome all right let's win again
um
i think we have a little bit more let's
try it harder harder
uh opponent
let's try a really really tough computer
let's try um
xavier and 1900 i will not i will
probably not beat this guy i will
probably not beat this guy unless i
think about every single move
um
there's a high chance i will not beat
this
this and that i think
if this i need to do something like this
in case that happens
that get this guy out castle
very annoying
um
unsure what to do here
do something like that
welcome back to pogchamps 4 presented by
coinbase and it is a pleasure to be
joined by
uh the two players whose match we just
witnessed tech tone and qt cinderella qt
congratulations on an excellent match
uh it was great to watch and i wanted to
start by asking you you have pogchamps
experience how much do you feel like
that plays a role
in this pog champs do you feel less
nervous do you feel like uh you've sort
of settled into your game because your
play has been excellent
no i i mean no i think
i think
i think i'm mad because apparently nick
who i'm playing next sucks
bad he sucks the at the video game and
i'm gonna win and that means i'm gonna
be the worst player in winner's bracket
or if somehow he beats me i could be the
best player in losers bracket and i'm
just mad that i don't want to be in
winners bracket
so you're saying it's a lose-lose yeah
it's a lose-lose because i don't want to
be the loser in a loser bracket like
tacton yuck
how dare you
i had i had a game plan going into this
i was like number one i shouldn't lose
to him but number two in case i am i
could just i had i brought a 2d girl
because i see that you get easily
distracted by those
so i thought yeah that'll be easy good
plan yeah
yeah
well okay um i mean i think your
gameplay today worked pretty well
against tech tone cutie but tech tone
how do you think the hippo is going to
do today
are you going to keep rocking it or who
the taught him the hippo okay first
of all qt
let me tell you okay the hippo is a
strat that has been passed down by my
ancestors for three generations and the
fact that you're going to come in here
okay let me tell you you are sitting
there playing the metastrat of the
bulgarian somersault and you think that
you're good because you know nothing
stonewall no it's
called the bulgarian somersault and
maybe you'll you'll learn a couple
things if you actually get off your ass
and do something first of all i don't
even like jinx okay she sucks you should
have brought vi she's way better second
off i will always play the hippo
because that's how i've been raised i've
been taught once again i am loyal to the
hippostat i will never change it
because i like it unfortunately i didn't
do it justice qt blundered her rook
unlucky
but she still beat my ass which sucked a
lot
i really thought really thought i had
round one not gonna lie
but it didn't work out
yeah
i didn't think you had any of them
oh my god i would strike you down where
you stand what does that mean
we're terrified he's speaking nerd to me
do you feel attacked on that
what's the name of that maneuver where
you push your rook up and you bring your
queen to the corner is it the tommy
tommy pickles tommy pickles do you feel
like that might have led to some trouble
in the second game because you lost that
night is the tommy pickles going
anywhere or is it just well it's like
it's
i'm sure that it's probably a good move
i mean it seems like a good move right
you have the bishop and then you can
move it and then if anybody threatens it
you have the queen to jet pack behind an
aka pull off the tommy pickles
i mean
i know it's good i just don't think i
know the right time to do it it's like
castling you know generally whenever i
castle it's because well i mean i
don't know what else to do might as well
castle so it's the same thing with the
tommy pickles i feel like i'm doing
something wrong i'm just not sure what
it is
no it's a pretty pretty reputable
maneuver nemo
dot com and logging in tech tone that's
what you're doing wrong okay
all
[Music]
does ludwig know that you're talking
like this does ludwig know that you're
talking like this to someone who could
be a friend does he know
does ludwig know that i'm talking like
this hang you where it hurts cutie
[Laughter]
you
do not want to push that button oh yeah
you're talking the airpods i've
learned long enough that at this point i
should mute my mic before
so don't worry i won't respond to that
and all i will say is check
mate techton all right
that's all i will say to you it's a fair
point it's good
we got two matches into one and um uh we
hope that one day you two will have uh a
chance at a revenge grudge match maybe
we can just scrap the chest and do a dis
battle instead because i feel like we
got
two entirely different batches today one
for jessica for the disses both were
absolutely amazingly entertaining indeed
thank you cutie thank you tech tone
thank you awesome match and uh good luck
in that was a pleasure tech time
see you later
not in losers actually i won't see you
later
wow
well they were just firing off they
didn't have enough action on the
chessboard
that chess game just continued straight
into the interview that's what we love
to see friendly
uh atmosphere of friendly
competitiveness tech tone and cutesy
cinderella and before we
before we jump into our final match of
the day we want to remind you that
pogchamps 4 is presented by coinbase
whether you're looking to make your
first crypto purchase or you're an
experienced grandmaster trader coinbase
has you covered get exclusive rewards
when you spend with coinbase card and
much more visit coinbase.com
chess and get five dollars in bitcoin
when you sign up and verify your account
great stuff coming your way by coinbase
and great stuff coming your way in the
third match today we have fundy and
nikkei 30 facing off right in the other
side of this break don't go anywhere
when we come back we'll have our final
match of the day
good advantage
um
i want to try to take
while getting my queen out okay so if i
make a pawn move
um
i just want to trade i want to trade
because he's so far developed i feel
like this would be a good trade like
either takes or i take
plus this is defended as well
okay so he's getting involved on that
um
i gotta make sure this guy is backed up
too
so
if i take he takes or with the other one
let me back this up first
i want to have some good pawn structure
if i can use another piece that would be
ideal
but i do have oh i should have pinned
his knight i should have pinned his
knight
okay what are you planning buddy
why would you do that i can just that's
a free take i don't think you realize
that and now my my knight's defended as
well by two pieces
that's good
ten minutes yup ten minutes till it
starts
okay well you're defending that pawn
what happens if you take that what do
you have access to
there in the night
um
if he pushes up i'm not gonna like that
i think i just develop
i'm down i'm down if you take i'll just
take it back you don't have any of your
pieces developed really
yeah okay i was afraid of that because
now he has my my queen pin for there
anyway
but um
hmm i can't get my bishop out now
i mean that's just a free piece though
oh wait he can take
i should have thought about that before
i did that but look i just want to get
this out of there anyway um
okay uh i'm down to trade
because he's he further developed that
piece so this would be a good trade like
i would benefit from that if he did go
for it
um heck yeah you're not defending that
why not
he's got that and that so we can throw
my queen oh i didn't even notice that
okay so you're threatening this and this
and then you're gonna go for either oh
you're gonna go for either that or
okay i'm not too worried about that
right now
because
if i move
okay okay okay okay okay uh let's do
this so it's defending this right here
for the knight but um i also have my
bishop for this piece too so he's his
his knight is pit like he's got to back
up
or he loses that
um okay
i didn't think about that so now i lost
my queen interesting so did i need to do
that then i think i did if i didn't do
that
and he moved that there
no i could have just moved
yeah i definitely didn't need to do that
oh i don't even need to waste my queen
actually
i can't castle because yeah
okay
oh okay so you go
what are you planning
what are you planning sir
i really want to get rid of this
nothing's defending that
let me just put a halt to this real
quick
the thing is though if i take
i'm surprised he didn't there
okay so i just made a big mistake
yeah i made a mistake
no it's not checkmate
why do you do that
oh
own streaming history while supporting
your favorite gamers and streamers by
buying their digital collectibles on
eternal
collecting these sometimes hilarious
always epic gaming and irl highlights
directly benefits the creators while
providing you the fans something unique
and special to keep
sign up on eternal.gg build your own
collection and feel the thrill of
ripping digital packs and viewing
amazing moments in the marketplace
[Music]
welcome back to pogchamps 4 presented by
coinbase
and nemo we've seen some epic actions so
far and we've got one more matchup
coming your way between fundy and nick
a30
nemo what have your thoughts been on the
matchup so far do you feel like the last
matchup is going to be as epic as the
first two
i feel like this last matchup is going
to be really epic
but um you know nothing quite compares
to the matchup of the previous game
but we all know there i'm mostly talking
about the disc battle that went on
between beauty and tactile but this
match will probably be really exciting
on the board i think fundy is very well
prepared he's been grinding and
obviously nikkei 30 has been working
hard on chess recently as well so lots
of exciting things
indeed and definitely quite the rating
difference i think nick has an uphill
battle to climb but what i really
noticed in the way that nick played
against techtone
is his he has very methodical approach
he thinks very logically
and he really tries hard i mean he's
calculating he sees a lot of stuff i
think he needs
more training and basic principles to
put everything together but he's going
to be a tough matchup as we see a four
well potentially a four nights defense
if nick develops his final night
to c6 which is very likely i don't know
much about fundy's openings
but he
pretty sure he knows what he's doing in
the opening
bundy plays solid stuff and
it's always good stuff
let's see
how fun he's approaching the opening
he'll protect this pawn if not we can
take it
a bit of a weird move you can just take
the pawn here
okay
yeah c6 isn't great
something like that
there's a few things you can do now to
try and keep my knight out
i think the best option is that
because that still wins upon back i'm
quite sure
because i'll have to go back and then he
has two attacking on this pawn right
think that's the best move
doing that yeah okay
um now the question is
i could also just like defend it like
that
okay and that just gives me control over
md4
after that if these spawns need to be
protected i have this and i have that
i mean d6 by
by nicholas
uh by nickwood would force that knight
out instead he goes b5
trying to push the spawn of b4 and
isolate the c4 pawn but as fundy
indicated he can now go bishop d3
and lend another defender to the e4 pawn
and
it just seems nemo nick's got some of
the pieces in place but
he's not really emphasizing development
here and he could get in a lot of
trouble he already is in a lot of
trouble opening wise
yeah this is one of those positions
where i'm just not sure where black's
pieces are going to go
um the light square bishop is
covered by you know every single pawn
and the dark tour bishop is blocked by
the queen and
you know the knight on 8th eight sorry
b8 can't go to c6 so has to go through
a6 and stuff so right really not sure
what's going on here
yeah i mean nick is also taking quite a
bit of time d6 would still be the best
move i wonder what he's thinking about
and if only we could take a look at
someone's stream i could get taken back
[Music]
let's threaten this
right here
let's start in his night
because i'm defended by the queen and
okay i could also move my bishop out and
threaten his queen but he would do the
play
where
he puts his pawn out
so i would have to go back if i go back
that's good because my knight's
defending okay so i put my bishop out
here move it back defending um and i
like where my bush is standing and then
all i need to do is move my knight and
then i can castle on the right side i
like that
okay
but i also got to pay attention what
he's doing because his bishops are
technically in play
bundy's got a crazy night stack here
knight takes c6 on the blue square
i don't think he's going to do that
yeah
that f3 back seems a lot safer
okay
and bishop g4 he could have taken the
pawn on e4 but the problem there is that
this didn't happen i'm just showing what
could happen that queen on e4
is going to get stranded white's going
to castle go rookie one
and that potential skewer is going to be
a big problem so instead i kind of like
the decision to go bishop g4 and if i
were funny i would go bishop d3 here
reinforce that pawn
let's hear what fundy's thinking
to protect both
i like this spawn this is a good spot
because it protects both this pawn from
being attacked and it protects this from
being attacked i'm quite happy with this
so we do this now
yeah we do this now
then if this comes we just take it if
this gets taken we take with the queen
if this gets sticking we take with the
knight
if nothing happens we try and push this
guy out
or or get our bishop here and castle
be good thinking here for fundy
that's the plan
[Music]
he's approaching the game very logically
and i also have this counter attack
which is
decent but there's that yeah you can
tell he's very experienced
and we have d5 now we just have this and
i pushed the knight out yeah
tonight here establishes that pawn bang
bang
bang think a good example
night here i would take he takes i take
what's
his calculations do mesmerizing i was
just going to say a good example of how
beginners
often go wrong is i think a more
advanced player would see that there's a
pin the knight is not hanging
and um
would play move like g6 or develop the
other night but
i think when you're new to chess it's
more tempting to move a piece back even
when it's not technically attacked i
would be impressed if nick doesn't move
the knight i think
very methodical and there's a shot
there's a chance but i'm more worried
that he's going to play
okay
and so
he is
okay
seven look
don't you dare
okay kudos
the problem is if honey plays but if he
moves something in front of him
i might forget that eh i might forget
that so okay now you can take my
okay
okay but now that night doesn't have
great school
cool
um
why can't he draw arrows i use my pawn
you use your queen i use my knight
i win the trade nope
you'll do nothing
conor mcgregor
you'll do absolutely nothing
i feel like i'm a genius right now
no you didn't
oh i thought my night was right here bro
i thought my night was right here
what have i done why did i think my
knight was up one
um
okay if i take what's the consequence of
taking right now
he moves his queen
yes i want to take because here's the
thing
you're
no no no no no no no no no i mean he's
already in huge trouble
oh
no he's down a pawn now and now the
bishop hangs and the pawn on c6 hangs
the whole position is hanging yes i
think right take it or i'll take your
queen you'll do nothing you'll do
nothing
okay i'll take your queen if you go for
that
don't do it it's exciting i think he's
only thinking about white's worst move
yeah
i think fundy is deciding what to take
right now of course he should take the
bishop
okay okay what are you gonna do
oh
nick is not gonna like that
i'm taking that font
oh i didn't see that
oh
i did not see that i tunnel visioned on
it
he's also threatening my knight right
now which i don't like
um but then if he takes that
dude there's no way he takes that
because then i would trade i would win
there's no way he takes my knight right
now so i'm going to take this piece i
just i earned this
how can i get a bishop out of the way
that's going to open up the position
he's going to use his knight
but i'll win the trade i win the trade i
win the trade if he if he takes with his
knight and pawn i take with my
knight
and my queen and i win and then also
if i can get if i can castle
and get my rook into play right now and
like we could get something going on in
the center his rooks are kind of pinned
right now he's got to develop his pawns
yeah i mean obviously he's
over excited about a pawn but
that's something which comes with
experience you sort of begin to realize
what's important in a position and
what's not i think the fact that he he
wins the trade
is creating excitement when he's just
down a piece his king is really weak
and bishop g5 what an excellent move by
fondy
getting the bishop out with tempo pretty
much instantly i mean he's just thinking
on his opponent's time as well he's just
really calculating like hey how am i
going to develop my pieces he's got
control of the center he's also a piece
now like hard to imagine this position
going bad for him at all
he's just so solid so stable
yeah
surprised
bundy's clearly very experienced i think
you can just see
in the way that he's playing
uh he's moving confidently quickly queen
h4 here would be great you can also just
take the knight
yeah he did nick seems very happy though
i like seeing that yeah he's just
excited i i love that like he just has
permanently good vibes it's crazy it's
great it's actually what
one quick way the game could end if nick
takes with the queen and fundy plays
knight takes d5
queen d7 mate is going to be a big
threat and
that's something i could see
happen like nick plays h5 or something
and chases the queen
yeah bundy might be tempted to take the
apart let's see because if he takes it
yeah fundy wants to take it upon
right
to attack the
it queen leave the option for rook to d1
open so
yeah that d7 square is just very
concerning in general yeah i'm okay with
this
i'm okay with this this is good
this is a-okay chat
this is so okay that you guys should
like definitely consider twitch prime
maybe yeah
see that he countered nicholas nick
counter-attacked his queen
i don't think he did
but oh he might have he's playing so
fast
it was not a good idea to trade queens
though leaving the queens on the board
would be basically mating this is
crazy where's he from by the way what
flag is that netherlands oh wow there's
a lot of people from netherlands
not wrong don't do it
don't do okay now i gotta start thinking
ahead again
you're going d7 or f7 in which case you
can take my rook
here you're going d7 you're going f7 so
i got to defend that but it is defended
right now
what are you planning or you're going to
take that
so
oh i wouldn't mind do i castle like a
castle here and okay wait one two oh i
forget how it castles i think the rook
will be here right i think so
oh shoot
okay not a night out i'm gonna defend
this pawn man
oh
but wait but wait maybe it worked in the
hmm
it's always one two with the king and
then i think that the rook takes over
that's what i think anna said i forgot
though one two with the king
yeah
shoot
shoot okay
oh you're getting spicy with it
knight f7 whoa okay wait can i put you
in check i can't so i have to do this
and this is a discovery pawn take but
you're going to move your knight to here
or here
but you don't have anything or you're
going to move it here and take my pawn
in which case then you can take my rook
or my pawn which i respect it unless i
move my rook up here to d7 and it's
defending the pawn i wish i could draw
arrows for you guys but it's not letting
me so
i'm shocked bundy is not playing knight
outside one of them
here
yeah okay i figured that okay so
do you just not want the fork maybe well
now i mean he doesn't this is good
because now i can move my rook to to 8d
to d8 oh my god
oh but he's got his bishop defending
dudes
he's amazing
yeah he is i practice this in puzzles
bundy is not saying anything here bishop
takes juice
i thought i had there though i'm well
he's still completely pretty happy with
myself
and i just want to see what he does
before i think about anything else
because my brain's hurting
i thought too much but i do want to line
it up with the
oh but then i'll take with the knight so
i need to make sure his
how can i get him to move his knight
it's on a white square i think i just
take his pawn and threaten his rook
yeah if i can get his rook off there bro
if i can move my rook
[Music]
okay well here hear me out on this
no i can't see i could trade i could
take his pawn and then we both take each
other's
rooks
or
oh i think i have to man i can't put him
in check right now i think i have to
this is the best case scenario
oh but wait i can't because he's gonna
put me in check so i need to take his
piece back therefore
if i move this here his knight ends up
taking it so he goes there
i go there i'll end up losing both of
them i'll end up losing both of them
so
if i go here he
okay wait i do this
he does that
yeah i know i don't like this because if
i move my rook here he takes with his
knight first and then
okay
i can't take with my king
i can
someone in chat has been confused but
he's got the spirit i was had such good
dude
no now he loses everything oh no no no
yeah now
now it's important for fundy to take the
rook on d8 first to keep the pin and i
think nick forgot that now he can take
the other rook
and white is up just a little bit of
material just a tad just a tiny bit
light amount of material and he plays
the long castle with the check to flex
i would say fundy
okay let's listen in he could have
played better but
he didn't let it out of his out of his
clutches
let's see how he converts
yeah this should be fine we have a lot
of pawns
i i i think i think we have this
especially now i wanted to go here or
something if it goes here it's it's
great
yeah okay
that king is getting chased
doesn't mean that
let's say he goes down if he goes down
we have this and that's night
[Music]
oh yeah that was a nice one
he's gonna collect all of the pawns
there's no mate here is there no i'm
just gonna
i don't know what else to do
well that means there's a risk of
stalemate right so all the better for
nick right exactly
ooh check
okay i think you should resign
in
this is very good
unfortunately the defensive resources
have now been exhausted
that g3 is good can we not get i guess
we can't get made somehow can we
let's try and kick him out
we can go here
again at this
that'd be very good i think
oh
bishop
now the whole kingdom is on fire we can
take that is because the other rook is
protecting my broke meaning his king
cannot take it yeah
white is up
and i think we can
we can we can win
this will just be the only annoying
thing because i will have to do like
some iffy i almost want to see if he's
still strategizing and trying to make a
draw
he can't go down with this rook
yes he's gonna go down with that rook
that was a weird one why'd he do that
shouldn't he have just done like one
little change
oh you're pinching me
oh you're taking my pawn
stalemate as possible if he takes that
he's not going to use this
one okay it's basically a draw this
could be a stalemate
okay how can i think about what he's
gonna do he's gonna move his bishop
right here
okay
if he moves his bishop right here i
didn't i didn't know there was one
i learned new things every day
you just can't see
yeah i mean but if he moves it here
okay not the play right here let me just
try to get a little bit closer oh
we got the free moves
oh yeah okay now he's doing the
staircase thing
yeah i lost you here well hey guys how's
your day you guys want to talk right now
i'm kidding okay let's have a good
conversation we got two minutes
okay
i feel pretty good about that not gonna
lie like
he's got 1200 for anything i feel like i
did i put up a fight
wow
well nick is super wholesome that was
great to see even though he's new to
chess anymore i think we can all
appreciate he you cannot say he didn't
try his best and uh there are definitely
sparks there that that could be brought
out
honestly
so passionate and like he seems to be
loving the game even though you know
this game didn't go the best for him so
i'm just like super happy for him like
he seems to have had so much more fun
than all of us here combined indeed
unfortunately for nick fundy is just a
beast he's clearly very experienced and
nick with the white pieces in game two
he's gonna have a shot
and i think he's going to do everything
he can
to give fundy a challenge so don't go
anywhere we'll have game two for you
right after this break we'll be right
back
[Music]
we put on a good fight we put on a good
fight guys and i'm proud of it
heck yeah
okay let's see where the next game is
starting
i'm so proud of my performance right now
i'm so proud of me
i'm so proud of you guys guys i want to
read your messages okay give me two
seconds actually three minute break we
got a three minute break okay
oh wait i gotta see if anna has any
advice hold up wait a minute
wait a minute
hold up
let's see
okay i don't want to be getting that so
i want to block how do i block
oh okay
you turned off the wrong thing i didn't
even know i turned anything off honestly
okay
wow it's fun
um let's see real quick
oh no
what would you do no we're not watching
what would you do
um chess
okay they are taking a break
nice wow
oh hey what's up guys i'm watching the
broadcast okay uh i actually want to get
uh
let's see
okay oh no
okay wait anna call do you want to do a
call i'm actually curious of your advice
if you're allowed to give me advice i
mean i think so before the game starts
but uh yeah i'm pretty proud of myself
right there and now watch me just like
completely throw everything now
he's good though fundy's really good
oh man
okay
hello okay what did you think how about
like what are you doing
yeah
you did great thank you
let's go
so did you notice anything like that
that i could kind of do or is it kind of
just like play how i played kind of
thing
um
what i noticed well first of all you did
great with your time management i feel
like you didn't like overthink things i
think that was great thank you uh what
you could focus on is uh try to play it
simple just develop focus on developing
okay i like the queen e7 idea but i
think it started with c6 or the set your
third move
because
uh you need to defend the pawn because
it was under attack like they'd move the
knight to c3 and you can like mirror
that okay okay it's the same idea and
after that like it will become very
natural develop your pieces and then you
get like
a good simple position because after
that it got really a little bit
complicated your queen was on e7 and
then like at some point you just start
to feel like okay how do i develop my
pieces because you couldn't hassle your
bishop on f8 was stuck and then the
problem started to like arise yeah
okay okay so um main takeaway is i'm
sorry i just totally forgot i blanked
i'm like no now i'm getting nervous and
now i'm getting ready don't worry don't
worry you're doing great honestly you
did great
i'm really proud of you but what you
should focus on is just develop just
develop
yeah develop
the world chess championship
[Music]
the champion magnus carlsen
the challenger
jan nippon
watch the only twitch broadcast with
live video from dubai on chess.com tv
your home for the world chess
championship
and we're excited to bring you the world
chess championship with exclusive video
cams on twitch
starting in november magnus carlson
against jan and pam nishi make sure to
tune in block off the whole month of
november it's coming your way so very
soon with exclusive video cams cannot be
better and
well if you're inspired you want to be
as good as magnus check out learn chess
with dr wolf the virtual chess coach
available now with a one week free trial
on ios and android if you're new to
chess or just need a refresh the virtual
chess coach will show you everything you
need to know
it's the next best thing to learning
from a real person download
dr wolfe now
all right we've got potentially one more
game left in today's pock champs
brought to you by coinbase it's been an
amazing day so far and right now we're
watching fundy play against nick830
funny winning the first game but nemo we
were all taken with nick's wholesomeness
and his optimism and his fashion and i'm
sure we'll see that again in the second
game
i uh i'm just laughing at this fox that
fundy has
that fox is great
three or more
i turn i turn into like uh
i turn into a laugh track machine that
that that that is like half broken and
only triggers every 30 seconds or a 30
minutes i can watch that box for like i
turn it into a laugh
that laughs whenever the joke is
directed at me and that's the extent of
interaction you will have
that's the extent
give him a little
mic as well all right chad let's do this
come on
um
i hope for night here because i don't
know anything else and even if mike goes
here and i go night here i have no clue
how to go from there
knight c3
this is the close sicilian
a little bit different from the open
sicilian
um but probably a little bit i should
probably i should probably quit the
music i have no idea right
um this is probably like my go-to
opening
while at the same time my go-to i have
no clue what i'm doing
i think bishop i think he's being modest
isn't it
they're stupidly annoying because i
can't i can't kick it out they'll take
i'll stack my stupid pawns it's annoying
bishop d3 thank god
five is the theoretical best line i
would say
agree do i how do i be annoying so is
this good
i remember that yeah they should be
crazy backwards pawn right
was it this that
they talked about the other bishop i
take they take i take
is it this that
i think it is
e6 is great
yeah e6 is a great move preparing d5
and the issue with this bishop on d3 is
that now this other bishop
that i've highlighted in blue has a hard
time
getting out you can't push the d-pawn
out you can fianchetto it and i'd be
pretty impressed if nicolas figures out
that's how he should position his
bishops
what do you think is he going to do that
um
but i think
we should take a listen on his stream
see what he thinks i'm not entirely sure
yeah this is a cool position i don't
want to move anything else because this
is defending that this pawn is defending
that
although actually that's fine because i
actually have a queen here right now
everything's like defended i feel like
he's actually taking quite a long time
this is actually really good
okay
he was drawing the arrows for beef huh
okay so you're gonna attack that so if i
attack that
you will okay but here's the thing if i
let you attack
why wouldn't i let you attack
you're not gonna attack
wait you're trying
if i attack then my queen is separated
by a pawn
um okay you're not gonna attack
you're not going to
but i want to push that fight so look
boom
boom you win the trade
because all i got was pawns
yeah you don't i don't want to do that
so i'm going to let you attack
and what i need to start doing
is if i move this here you can take that
because it's not defended that's the
only problem with that wow he so i could
just move up one and it's not going to
be wow
you figured it out fair enough see that
was the fianchetto we wanted
he figured it out and i love the logic
first he thought about taking a pawn
twice he figured out that he can't do
that
and
now by the way bishop d6 has been played
that blunders the pawn i think funny
forgot that now the queen is no longer
protecting d5
and if nicholas if nick is is careful
he'll notice that he can now play he
takes d5 no but g3 is
and it's not a terrible move but it's
not amazing it weakens the king's side
we did only want one fianchetto
mostly the
b2
to b3 fianchetto because there the dark
tour bishop can hop there in the next
move but if you play g3 then it's a
little bit harder for your live square
bishop to reroute all the way to g2
so yeah that's why here the g3 fiance
doesn't serve as much as the b3 fiance
we're not as hyped about it
i agree i think maybe partially the
reason why he played it is he was
worried about the bishop having too much
influence so he wants to castle perhaps
uh and he didn't want the bishop aimed
at the h2 fund total speculation though
um
he might also have completely other
ideas that
that i'm not noticing but yeah bishop b2
would be
would be the best move here he castles
okay
so perhaps that was his idea fondy
should also castle and he's positioned
his pieces very nicely
but nothing clear going on so far nick
has done pretty well in the opening
let's have a listen in on fondy
if i do this and he goes here i get that
and that just solidifies the center
really nicely doesn't it
this
that
ah
this is annoying
if i if i do if i do this first
and then that yeah i'm happy with that
this first
then this
they go here
i do that solidify the center castle
[Music]
don't need to castle just yet i think
that's okay
he's preparing d4 he doesn't want the
knight to get that b5 square right
okay
or just go back
yeah next should go back
an even cooler move here would be to
play e5
yeah e5 is like one of those that's a
little harder to spawn but it's a great
in-between move technically
nick going knight a4
fundy is almost for sure gonna go b5
here and force the knight to be in keto
that is not that's not
yeah
that night is not looking too hot on the
rim
remember nights on the rim are kind of
paper you don't want to put them there
they definitely control a lot more
squares when they have when they're in
the center so
not the best place for the night but to
be fair it's really difficult to find a
better spot dude there wasn't a lot of
skirts to go yeah
nobody wants to nobody wants to drop the
knight back like that
another great move here would be to go
e5
and as i say that he actually plays it
uh and the idea is to open up a diagonal
for the bishop and the problem that i
have with nixon with g3 is that the
knight on f3 is unprotected so flat gets
the bishop to g4
and then castles and then pushes the f
pawn out i know that's a lot of moves
but the knight on f3 could get in a lot
of trouble
yeah um and i'm worried that nick might
not notice
this kind of idea let's listen in yeah
but i think that's a play and a half
right there i think that's the play
where he is
but then you're moving the queen there
and then i lose a trade unless i move
the pawn up no this is good okay so
assuming he doesn't move these up like
let's say he does this
i can take but he's gonna do this right
he's gonna bring his queen down
okay
in which case he does that but he
wouldn't trade it i don't think he
hasn't been known to trade at least from
when i played him
i feel like we're playing really good
chess like this is textbook
i'm pretty proud
you're playing well but h6
okay guys i still gotta go back to my
original plan boom take it with your
pawn bro take it
take it take it so i could get this
defending that piece as well oh that'd
be sick
actually i kind of don't want that i
just want to move out of the way
the bad news about one of your opponents
do things is that they don't bare boys
right man i'm up on the clock right now
are you serious
how the heck am i like how's my game
improved so much we got the best coach
in the world i think that's like oh
[Music]
okay i still like the idea this covered
so if i move there
you're gonna take that
crazy
so i have to go back in which case then
you can move your bishop that's a good
pin so now i got to do something in
order to make you stop
will he see queen what can i do
i don't think so
it would be absolutely this queen here
oh i can take the rook oh
[Applause]
oh my god i'm playing some good chess
right now i'm playing some games playing
some good jobs right now oh lee
angelina jones let's go
because like this
and then if i can get my bishop
oh my god now he's got an even more
powerful screw
you just moved your knight out of the
way okay
so then on the ball
and then we cancel just happy the
tactics are being spotted these are some
really high levels bishop right there
this is a useless mission
let's see if fundy is disconcerted at
all i don't think he is
like funny is
keeping it under control
i am a little bit of a time
only a little bit though
okay um
so now what's the plan do we just castle
now
[Music]
i think we do them
i think we just castle
yep gasoline is great okay
hey boots
hey buddy
oh is that his cat
um
[Music]
she's right in front of my
i'm playing chess buddy
i gave her a bunch of pats chad no
worries no worries
i like the concept of this video
nick that was his idea
i like talking
that's okay
i gotta create an attack somehow
go here
queen f6 would be a good move
yeah it seems like he's intending to
play it i just want to show really
quickly
what crazy resource nick had after
knight g6
he could have sacked a knight on f7 very
hard move to play
then you swing the bishop to c4
and the king can't abandon the knight so
it's got to go forward
and i'm not sure exactly how white
should play here but the move queen f3
comes to mind
with the idea if king e7 then you've got
checkmate on
f7 apparently that's not the best move
maybe just a calm pawn to d3
would be strong intending f4 look at
that
right that is a very nasty move yeah
maybe you can also play f4 in order to
open up the entire f file that could
also be
yeah something something like that and
then maybe knight c5 or d3 but this this
leads to a very strong attack but it's a
very advanced idea
even if you play eg takes you have e5
after so a lot of really great ideas for
why here it's just very difficult to
find
extremely and you know what i'm really
concerned about here
why did funny play bishop b6 i think he
wants to play and bishop a3
by nick that's a very nice move
attacking the pawn on c5 the guy is
playing out of his mind i think fundy
wanted to play queen d7 but if he does
that immediately he walks into a
potential fork on b6 he wanted to put a
bishop on g4
i think that's his ultimate idea that
would trap the queen
and he plays b5 and nicholas can take
the pawn on c5
will he see it
you see it's nike sick but he can't do
that here
oh actually the queen can take it what
am i saying why am i even considering
that
um
will he see knight takes pawn
okay so if i okay here's the thing so
i'm going to lose that so if i go if i
go there
but not with the bishop
he would take
no i still lose it
i think i got a backup don't go to b2
unless i can do something here
no i can't
oh no now funny can win the bishop if he
plays knight v2 that's well developed
yeah i gotta back up seven times could
be even stronger
well done captain sir
i think bundy is going to win that
bishop yeah
there it is he was so close to playing
that oh my god a lot of i think newer
players should trust their intuition you
want to take my
i raise you on captain
i raise you a bishop for a bishop
it's not a bishop most people i feel
like most people like people like me
would would probably just trade or
something you know but i saw that he has
the advantage there he's got um
okay
an eye for an eye
oh but actually you're gonna see that
the queen can take unless
if i go here you go there no
i go there you go there
i go there you go there i lose gg
um
so if
what if we do something
if i could do something here man
what can i do
no i need to get rid of these bishops um
let's just let's just do it rather than
lose that i might lose that opportunity
trying to look for something
so
yeah
this ain't good
yeah the problem is i think fundy's
gonna go queen d7 nemo and then bishop
g4 and that's gonna trap the queen i
just don't see how
nick is getting out of it at all
yeah this is rather difficult for white
to play i mean that queen on h5 was
doing so much for the position a little
bit earlier but now it's a little bit
misplaced because fundy's king side is
looking pretty
strong pretty well protected
yeah bundy can also play dc and expose
the attack on the bishop he can also
play cb
nick is again he's trying to create
counter play i think he's got the right
instinct he understands
when things are going wrong you have to
mix things up but he doesn't quite have
the tools in his toolkit yet uh to
figure out a way how so i think
okay see takes before not the best
recapture but funny is very solid he
doesn't he doesn't go for anything crazy
he just sort of you know he makes the
simple moves and he doesn't blunder and
you can go very very far
uh doing that i think he's probably
gonna take that pawn now
yep
this one i can force this
bishop out of the way yep the wheels are
coming out here for fun
nick
i'm taking this that's solid this bishop
has to move now it means i can get this
unless he goes there
oh
i should be one who is deserved
ugly move that's the best spot for
bishop for his bishop
i think i i think i opened it up good
enough for me to have a chance to win
i think this is okay a chance
chess
very small chance
oh no
panic panic
panic
it was working earlier but doesn't quite
work now because first of all h takes g5
is there and also secondly the bishop
just hangs
you could he's going to take the bishop
which is perfectly good there's no mate
on h7 thank you for moving that night
that was a horrible night that is i
didn't like a little bit
he was he was annoying a little bit
rough
no the wheels are coming off here
and uh oh f4 so you can see see i i know
it sounds absurd but what i'm talking
about is that nick he knows these plans
he just doesn't know exactly when to
apply them now fondy can take another
piece or he can take the pawn it seems
to be more in fundy style to take that
pawn
but we'll see
he takes the knight okay he's up three
pieces now nick wants to push that on f5
i think
that's check me okay thank you for doing
that now how do i do this wait wait wait
wait wait wait wait wait wait wait wait
wait wait wait wait wait-wait
take it
take it just to just
just take it off please
take it
there's something
where
no
why would you do that
am i missing something
i think we're forgetting about a phantom
knight on g5
yeah
i think he was actually thinking about
like king to g2 and rook to h1
i think is more what he was looking at
oh
even then and that takes so long
[Music]
yup you're absolutely right what are the
odds he takes that right now he might
still do it and he might not know what
i'm doing so
i'm just going to play like this
i'll open you under the secret i don't
know what he's doing either
there's a pun on h4 though it's all or
nothing
as long as he doesn't move that rook if
he moves it it is all or nothing indeed
we're saying he can take the pawn and
fork on f4
come on
come on don't miss knight f4 he doesn't
see it he's like oh my god this guy
sucks okay no that's not what we want to
do um
if i move my rook now he's gonna know
so here's what we gotta do
how can i get that
he just has everything covered
okay he can't move his pawn this is a
good thing
because he can't move his pawn forward
for his queen
yes yes yes
will you please take it sir but oh he
wants funny to take him and i don't have
my bishop
please and thank you please and thank
you tradesies come on just like at
junior high when you're trading the
yu-gi-oh cards and pokemon cards let's
do a little tradesy there's no way he
doesn't there's no way he lets me do
that if he takes us he loses if he takes
us it's checkmate
if he takes it
come on
bro how can i
wait
boom
boom boom
that's way too many moves
wait wait wait what if i move my knight
no
no it's necessary i'm like the no oh how
did i not see that oh i got so caught up
on this oopsies
well guys you know what
it was a valerant effort
valiant valorent valiant
yeah he's got small problems with the
number of pieces in the attack
uh a slight problem that's what happens
when you
want your opponent to do something
really badly but they end up not doing
it you know you can't let your chess
game
be dependent on your opponent because
your opponent might not do what you want
to do so yeah and if you could take your
own pawns i think chess would be a very
very different game fundy's got
checkmate in two this game is about ten
let's listen and he finishes that
finishes the game off
right
that's mate
[Music]
yup
yup and that's awesome
[Laughter]
uh
gg
man i i made a blender yeah i figured it
was terrible
yeah
well
you know what that was some incredible
passion
that was some incredible enthusiasm and
you know what i'm gonna suggest nemo you
can disagree with this but
normally the uh play of the game
presented by eternal lagi goes to the
winner but
in honor of nick's you know passion and
the fact that he did find some amazing
ideas
i'm going to vote that this knight g5
h6 and now seeing queen h5 i cannot
emphasize enough how hard that is for a
beginner to not move the knight and to
see that you can counterpin
so even though fundy played a phenomenal
pair of games
um
i'm going to vote for this segment to be
our uh play of the game presented by
eternal.gg what do you think nemo i
hundred percent agree with you queen to
h5 is such a hard tactic to find and you
know nick hasn't been playing just for a
real long time and has only a 400 rated
player was able to spot that hey that is
a pin and additionally i'm also
attacking f7 that is a really really
really good move so all the props to
nick honestly for you know working
through dude
the whole no process that was awesome
and if you agree with us if you think
this play deserves to be eternalized
remember to sign up on eternal.gg with
your twitch account and type eternal in
chat to vote the play of the games that
receive the most votes will be turned
into digital collectibles and dropped on
september the 12th with all proceeds
going to red a charity dedicated to
making mental health accessible
three lucky viewers who voted will win a
free pack and we will be announcing the
winners
wow we had three incredible matches in
today's popjam's action and don't go
anywhere we still have a post match
interview waiting for you on the other
side of this break we will be right back
see you guys soon
[Music]
do
welcome back to fox champs four
presented by coinbase and we have the
players
from the final match up nick 830 and
fundy here hello interview
hi
and uh fundy of course congratulations
to you excellent match but nick we were
very very impressed with your play we
saw clear improvement even from your
first from your previous match against
tech tone can you walk us through how
you were feeling queen h5 that was
particularly impressive so what's been
the secret sauce for you it was
terrifying never do that again never do
that again i was way too over ambitious
but the strategy was have an amazing
coach shout out to anna maya she's the
best and basically my whole game plan
that second game is like i knew fundy
was way way better and he had the strats
to win so i'm like i kind of over
committed on this strategy of using my
queen to kind of pin the king and then i
needed that rook also down there on that
same file if i'm not mistaken i forget
the terminology but um yeah i was trying
to go for that checkmate and i would
have had it i was trying to get him to
take my pawn but i think he saw actually
funny i wanted to ask you did you see
that strategy i was trying to get you to
take it and the moment you put your
queen there i was terrified throughout
the rest of the game i was talking to
myself continuously
one how do i get that queen gone and two
how do i get that night gone that night
with it was terrifying it's just not fun
it was it was not fun it was not fun
you're a good player
that was definitely an insane moment i
was you know i didn't want to doubt you
nick but we were talking a little bit
about like oh queen h5 is such a hard
move and i you know i think nick might
see it but it's just so impossible and
then you played it and we're both just
like you should have just not seen it
yeah i've been doing actually a lot of
puzzles and different things like that
so that kind of helps me kind of see
that stuff now and literally i spent all
day off stream just like playing chess
matches and doing those puzzles for like
five hours and i know i'm not crazy good
my rating is like 500 or something it's
nowhere near
how much time i'm putting into it how it
reflects but i mean i'm loving it and
it's so fun playing chess so uh i want
to keep improving because like it's
satisfying when it
when everything you practice kind of
happens and comes into fruition
that is absolutely great to hear i mean
that was actually going to be our second
question for you what is the plan to
continue to improve for the rest of the
tournament i mean you know it sounds
like you're having a great time doing
things do you have anything specifically
planned apart from you know the
the puzzles and the training and
yeah so i noticed that um i play a lot
better when i'm just having fun and
making jokes and stuff like the first
time we i played in part champs i was
super stressed and i was just kind of
really trying to get the win like i was
putting so much pressure on myself here
um like knowing that fundy had like a
rating of 1200 he was really good i'm
like hey i lost anyway let's have fun
with it and basically i feel like i was
a little more chill and i was able to
think a lot better because you know when
you're stressed like you're under
pressure and you can't think and i ended
up wasting a lot of time in that first
match-up against tekto so
yeah i feel like i'm pretty happy with
how i played and i'm just going to keep
doing it again and keep practicing
well the thing is right so you're by by
uh rank you're like 500 rated i was
struggling as like a 1200 right so that
says a lot thank you i was terrified of
of the second game it was actually
terrifying i didn't know what to do
yeah
your bishop was lining up spots you had
to not yet the queen i know the rook at
some point was gonna come in i'm like
how do i stop this
thank you i really appreciate that a lot
thank you
it was good
we were also impressed and funny one
more question to you you crushed it in
your group uh how do you feel about your
chances in the winner's bracket any
special preparation that you're gonna do
so
i don't know it's i'm actually kind of
excited uh i'm not i'm not one two two
to really punch myself down if i lose or
anything like that i'm just excited to
play against people that you know might
completely destroy me and then that just
tells me oh get better
i'm excited for that it's fun that's a
great mindset to have i mean so far i
would say there's not that many people
that can totally destroy you but
there are people and i i
okay okay there are people that can
destroy they've done it before
oh
monday is already scared okay
no no no no that's my revenge this is a
revenge all right let's go
very nice we'll keep an eye on your play
and nick thank you to you as well what
an awesome match and an awesome attitude
we appreciate it a lot you guys good
luck on the rest of your games
thank you thank you
good luck
see you later
all right what a match what an attitude
uh that was a great way to round off
today's pogchamps action as we have a
look at the standings in the four groups
and nemo not really a surprise that
fundy uh crushed it by a country mile
um really
any surprises here that jump out at you
from from these groups honestly i would
say not particularly i wasn't very
familiar with the people in group d so i
would say i had the least familiarity
family ah i can't pronounce english now
but i wasn't really sure about the
people in group d but i have coach fundy
i have coach box box before us i wasn't
super surprised when box boxes in the
lead for groupies he plays chess he does
play chess he's been in twitch rivals
he's been you know he's been doing a
little bit of chess
but a lot of these players are super new
as well so obviously a lot of exciting
things will be upcoming
indeed and speaking of exciting
tomorrow's matchups are mouth-watering
we've got croakies and puns
sapnap just a minx and then box box
against harry mack
pretty uphill battle there to be fought
by harry and to round it off we're gonna
have mr beast and jake and bake live so
make sure to block off your calendar
that'll be coming your way september the
5th that is
tomorrow and
we would like to announce the eternal
pack winners from september the second
we've got quite a few of them here so
eric sw12 jj jewel vlada vladajank and
many others as you can see here on your
screen are the winners of play of the
game presented by eternal.gg
from september
the 2nd great stuff and if you think
you've got what it takes to be a pog
champ yourself coinbase community cup is
where you can prove it get in on the
action for awesome prizes no matter your
chest strength
in this arena running every day during
poc jams four
uh use command exclam coinbase cup
that's exclam coinbase cop in the chat
for info
on how to join in
all right
and we will be rating some streamer nemo
name nemo i'm not sure
who
we will be rating you nemo and for those
watching on youtube make sure to stick
around and catch the premiere of the
recap of today's first match
uh five up against jake and bake live
and uh what a day it was
three hours went by in a flash as they
often do when we are watching pogchamps
so a huge thank you to the participants
a huge thank you to the production team
and of course nemo it is a pleasure to
commentate with you
uh this was such a fun day and to the
thousands watching and supporting your
favorite pop champs participant in the
chat
awesome day
and uh don't go anywhere because we will
be raiding nemo
and we hope that you tune in tomorrow
for more pogchamps action thank you so
much everybody
thank you have a great
thank you nemo have a great rest of your
saturday afternoon everybody and we'll
see you tomorrow for more jams
goodbye all right bye
[Music]
so
oh
[Music]
you